e
[Musique]
soit
ah ah
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui fait avec nous ce soir
philippe de gaulle
michel ott maria pacôme
jules edouard moustic
jean-marc mots
tonya kinzinger
steve
gabriel cohn bendit
je joue la tristesse
mais là bas
[Applaudissements]
et le blind test en ligne à
[Musique]
et maintenant
j'accueille philippe de gaulle
[Musique]
non
il
bonsoir amiral bonsoir monsieur
l'addition alors ce quel effet cela vous
fait d'être à la télévision est ce que
vous avez le trac quand vous venez à la
télévision oh moi j'ai pas de talent ni
de goût particulier pour la télévision
prêts provenant de la marine nationale
nous pratiquions la discrétion
ouais mais mon père c'est différent il
avait appris votre mère a appris d avant
guerre il avait d'abord compris
l'importance de médias il l'a appliqué
pendant la guerre bien sûr l'appel du 18
juin pour commencer et puis c'est un
métier qui l'a appris finalement au fur
et à mesure des années jusqu à le
pratiquer avec une certaine maîtrise
quand il est devenu président de la
république
moi je me souviens en mai 68 quand il a
fait son allocution à la à la radio on
était avec des amis étudiants
révolutionnaires dans un dans un parc
public et on l'a entendu à la radio il a
retourné tout le monde en vain discours
un qui est très très fort en radio oui
d'autant que la télévision ne marchait
pas ouais voilà il n'avait que la radio
et la radio sur transistors alors pour
ceux qui voudraient pas reconnu philippe
de gaulle est le fils de charles de
gaulle ancien inspecteur général de la
marine depuis 1986 sénateur ump de paris
alors évidemment c'est pas facile d'être
le fils du général de gaulle mais vous
avez accepté votre testa avec courage et
modestie vous dit j'aurais pu naître
fils de pygmées ou de banc tout le sort
en a décidé autrement
on ne choisit pas sa place pour vous
votre place implique plus de plus de
devoirs que de droits d'une certaine
façon
non je dirais autant de devoirs que de
droits il faut pas diminuer ce qui
s'étend de devoirs égaux ya droit
boyer tout à fait tout à fait ben oui
mais c'est ainsi il faut assumer
la place que le sort vous attribuez
ouais alors bien que fils du général de
gaulle vous n'avez jamais cédé à la
facilité à 20 ans vous choisissez
l'armée la marine
ensuite pendant la guerre vous sillonnez
la manche dans les vedettes lance
torpilles des forces françaises libres
donc une guerre très très courageuse
vous débarquez avec la 2e db et vous
participez à la meurtrière campagne
d'alsace donc tout le monde connaît
l'action de votre père pendant la guerre
mais on peut dire que vous aussi
philippe de gaulle vu une action très
très courageuse a oui je ne pouvais pas
être autrement qu'être en première ligne
y compris dans la deuxième division
blindée alors il ya eu deux mille livres
écrits sur le général de gaulle votre
père mais jamais le témoignage de
quelqu'un d'aussi proche son propre fils
vous êtes le dernier témoin privilégié
vivant vous dites après mois on fera du
roman vous êtes le dernier à pouvoir
certifier de ce qui s'écrit puisque ma
soeur aussi discrète que ma mère
garde le silence il n'y a donc plus
qu'un seul témoin et le moment est venu
pour moi de témoigner
après on écrira ce qu'on voudra mais en
moins aura-t-on le plus d'éléments que
possible et en tout cas plus que ce
qu'on en a maintenant à en juger par ce
qu'on écrit parfois enfin
d'affabulations ou deux interprétations
abusives
combien de fois ai-je entendu dire que
mon père disait l'intendance suivra oui
c'est vrai il n'a jamais dit ça au
contraire pour lui la tendance précédait
toujours
alors donc à 81 ans vous parlez philippe
de gaulle dans un livre événement un
livre d'entretiens avec l'écrivain
journaliste michel tauriac qui s'appelle
de gaulle mon père qui est édité chez
plon
alors le premier tome dont nous allons
parler aujourd'hui va jusqu'en 1958
c'est à dire jusqu'au retour du général
de gaulle au pouvoir le deuxième tome
paraîtra en février 2004 et j'espère que
vous serez de nouveau des nôtres pour
pour parler du suivant alors ce livre
évidemment fourmille d'informations
historiques et d'éléments plus personnel
à commencer par la difficulté à
s'appeler de gaulle
vous dites finalement vous pouvez pas
passer une journée aujourd'hui sans
entendre parler du général de gaulle
c'est vrai on a ses propres parents
disparus en soi même on vit avec eux
mais en plus je ne peux pas passer un
jour sans voir mon nom écrit le nom de
mon père pour une question ou une autre
un rang plus comme vous lui ressemblez
énormément vous le savez vous pouvez pas
aller dans le métro plus pâle au cinéma
c'est très difficile pour vous ça fait
partie de du statut ouais c'est ce qu'on
doit assumer c'est comme ça alors quand
avez-vous pris conscience du fait que
votre père n'était pas comme les autres
qu'il était différent voire supérieurs
aux tréteaux way très tôt je dirais 4 5
en 1
alors je sais que tous les petits
garçons se lisent mon père est
formidable elle est toujours le mieux et
cetera mai
tout de même je me suis aperçu que le
personnage central c'était toujours lui
même quand il ne disait rien et
d'ailleurs dans le louvre âge que je
publie on voit une photo du sous
lieutenant charles de gaulle au 33ème
régiment d'infanterie qui au bout de
table des jeunes à la popote en campagne
avec les officiers de son bataillon qui
a des vieux capitaine et à le commandant
en chef de bataillon il ya beaucoup de
mais on ne voit qu'un seul personnage
c'est lui n'arrête en bout de table
et pourtant s'il n'y a que lui qu'on
voit l'enfance assez difficile quand
même discipline assez ferme à la maison
est ce que votre père vous mettez des
baffes enfin des gifles non si vous
voulez me faire dire que nous avions une
éducation prussienne certainement pas un
débat fond n'en reçoivent est quand on
était petit d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
que la lionne réagi avec le lieu où
l'ours avec le petit il faut le ramener
dans le droit chemin et que faire avec
un petit qui met la main dans la soupe
la ville de nantes après voilà son ca et
bien c'était les coutumes du milieu
auquel j'appartenais il fallait être
dans un moule et répondre quand on vous
adresser la parole
voilà à table les enfants par les pattes
encore à table les gens qui ne parlait
pas si vous entendez interrogé par il
devient vais rien réclamer votre chanson
là si on les avait oubliés ou s'ils
n'avaient pas de cuillères ou de l'hymne
de nigériens ne vais rien dire
votre mère avait quand même la main un
petit peu plus lourde que votre père ma
mère avait besoin de s'affirmer un peu
plus ouais mon père avait une autorité
naturelle sur el rey qu'il en ait pas
besoin de s'imposer
votre mère était pas très maternelle à
ma mère était une mère parfaite
c'est à dire que ses enfants avaient
tout ce qu'elle pouvait leur donner
mais une les mignardises est pas née
caresser pour elle et sauf quand il
était très petit vos parents philippe de
gaulle former un couple la discrétion
s'impose et à celle que quand votre père
rentré à la maison
il embrasse et votre mère sur les joues
sur le ferons jamais sur la bouche
devant vous ah non jamais jamais jamais
vu non il embrasse fait c'était
considéré comme le comportement du
couple en public alors le père suivait
de près vos études
ils apprenaient des fables et des poèmes
par coeur pour vous les faire réciter
tout ça a un sens et il la prenait
lui-même ce qui lui fit lisait trois
fois le poème cas voilà et oui en ce
faisant se raser pour m'indiquer comment
on devait le réciter alors vous dites je
devais être parmi les dix premiers de la
classe il fallait que je sois avant les
autres c'était obligatoire oui il disait
ça m'est égal que
tu es un demi point si les autres en 0
alors finalement vous rentrez dans la
marine il sait jamais vraiment mêlée de
votre carrière ne l'a jamais jamais
beaucoup intervenu dans votre carré
militaire
finalement il a failli vous oublié dans
ses mémoires de guerre et là il a oublié
finalement vous étiez comportés en héros
pendant la guerre héros non pas quand
même et là il ajouté il a rajouté de sa
main sur le sont les manuscrits monfils
continue à se battre avec la 2e db
comment vous expliquez ça comment vous
expliquer que finalement il vous est
tellement mis de côté à ce moment là et
bien parce que il était en train
d'écrire ses mémoires de guerre mais il
ne raconte pas l'histoire de sa propre
famille a pas une
ce boîtier saint-louis la discrétion et
puis je lui ai dit à la fin tout de même
vous pourriez dire que votre propre fils
a fait le tour de bout en bout et pas à
l'arrière il a dit oui c'est vrai mais
je sais pas pour raconter l'histoire de
ma famille alors il a rajouté monfils
continue à se battre
il s'agissait de la libération de paris
point final il aurait pu peut-être ça
aurait pu arriver
écrire mon fils a été tué il n'a pas été
le seul ouais ouais vous en avez vous lu
de voir aussi peu de considération
finalement pour vos beaux faits d'armes
pendant la guerre pas du tout ils le
savaient ils savaient très bien ça ne
sert à rien d'être le fils du général de
gaulle quand il faut affronter deux
nuits sur un porte-avions est il faut
accosté à bateaux pourquoi il faut être
fair lentilles champ avec la première
ligne d'avants très il ça sert
absolument à rien alors c'est pas la
peine qu'ils s'emmêlent a alors sur le
plan historique philippe de gaulle vous
apporter un éclairage évidemment sur le
mois de juin 40
le refus de paul reynaud le président du
conseil de quitter la france
il ya sa décision à lui de partir en
angleterre de se jeter à l'eau dit il et
de s'en remettre à dieu cirque à un
moment et c'est un geste qui est
fondateur pour tous pour tous qui suit
après c'est qu'à un moment il est entré
dans la rébellion il a franchi le
rubicon il savait pas où il allait il a
été tout seul contre tous oui mais il se
considérait pas comme rebelle il était
secrétaires d'état du gouvernement et il
considérait que de la troisième
république et il considérait que le
reste est trans aux influences de
l'ennemi ne comptait pas voilà qu'elle
était toujours sous les lois de la
troisième république
il n'y avait pour lui aucun changement
régime et il ne se considérait pas comme
rebelle il considérait que c'est les
autres avaient failli mais lui continué
celle nouvelle cotiser comme il le
disait parce que c'est l'honneur
les tous nos alliés continuent le combat
aux côtés des anglais y compris ceux qui
sont envahis comme les polonais les
hollandais et tout il n'y a que nous qui
ne compteront pas c'est l'intérêt
supérieur de la france parce que il faut
qu'elle soit victorieuse à la fin avec
tous les autres et c'est le bon sens
parce que les allemands perdons alors
souvent se dit dans la vie d'aujourd'hui
soixante ans après on se dit qu'est ce
que j'aurais fait moi le 18 juin 40 est
ce que je serais parti à londres où
est-ce que j'aurais accepté finalement
l'occupation ou le pétainisme
c'est une question qui est central
toujours aujourd'hui dans la dans la vie
des français c'est une question qu'on se
pose très souvent
oui mais il y avait beaucoup de jeunes
gens à l'époque qui n'acceptait pas que
l'effondrement de la france que pour eux
ça paraissait incroyable
c'était d'ailleurs effectivement
incroyable ou bien le dire mais aurait
voulu se battre ou continuer et n'ont
pas pu parce qu'ils se sont trouvés très
vite bloqué alors vous et votre famille
philippe de gaulle embarquez donc à
brest sur un rafiot propos l'angleterre
et quand vous arrivez à falmouth vous
sait pas vraiment où est votre père le
général de gaulle et c'est là vous voyez
dans le journal un entrefilet 10 ans qui
a lancé un appel la veille donc en est
le 19 juin
oui il a été soumis à un rythme
absolument épuisant les dix derniers
jours des gouvernements français il
faisait l'aller retour de grande
bretagne france dans les 24 heures il
aller à tour et revenaient ils aller à
bordeaux il retournait à brest et par
conséquent il était fréquemment
grande-bretagne disons tous les 48
heures donc on savait que mon père
pouvait être en grande bretagne mais
nous n'étions pas sûrs de les retrouver
et nous avons traversé pour une autre
raison c'est comme j'avais une soeur
très infirme qui ne marchait pas et
qu'on ne pouvez pas déplacer en voiture
d'ailleurs n'avions pas de voitures ne
veut pas en train pas en quarts
alors ne pas nous laisser dépasser par
les allemands c'est la consigne que nous
avions partir du bretagne nord où nous
étions en vacances pour aller à nantes
ou à bordeaux avec cette fille infirme
ma mère a décidé que ça serait plus
simple arbre et prendre un bateau pour
aller en grande bretagne ce qu'elle
avait fait en 1914 déjà une fois alors
ensuite philippe de gaulle vous
commenter un certain nombre d'événements
historiques de la deuxième guerre
mondiale le sabordage de la flotte a
remercié le kébir laprise raté de dakar
l'assassinât de darlan la dénonciation
de jean moulin et surtout l'affirmation
du général de gaulle à l'issue de la
guerre pour imposer la france comme un
des vainqueurs pour redonner dit-il le
moral à la nation après que le ressort
était cassé
puisque l'effondrement politique était
devenue totale
ouais mon père a considéré qu'il n'était
pas un commandant d'art de forces armées
et qu'il défendrait les intérêts du
peuple français
il a toujours fait valoir autant à
l'ennemi qu'à ses propres alliés que le
peuple français était incontournable et
qu'il fallait toujours compter avec lui
c'est ainsi qu'il a commencé à apprendre
un rôle politique souvent d'ailleurs
inconfortable pour s'allier fille de
gaulle cette idée de dire aux français
finalement la france s'est bien
comportée de leur faire croire un petit
peu qu'ils ont tous été résistant
pendant la guerre ça partait d'un bon
sentiment
pour redresser le moral de la nation
mais on sait bien que c'est
historiquement c'est faux tout de même
nous ne sommes effondrés en 1940 parce
que nous à vous et y ont mal organisé
nous avions des préjugés militaire
périmés et nous étions mal comment des
ouais
car nous étions dans une république
était déjà très jugé ouais donc les
armées étaient mal commandé mais tout de
même il faut pas oublier que en mai juin
les français ont eu c'est 116000 tuées
et 600 mille blessés
oui mais quand nous étions tous seuls
oui mais quand même après après la
guerre quand votre père faisait les
comptes vous voyez le nombre de gens qui
avaient été dans la résistance sur sur
chez pam assure 40 ou 45 millions
d'habitants à l'époque ça faisait pas
beaucoup quand même il y avait 40
millions 39
il y avait beaucoup d'attentes east
c'est vrai mais il y avait quand même
une proportion de résistants qui petit à
petit mais a pu être répertorié monte
environ 40000 résistants patenté
enregistrés dans des réseaux une
centaine de milliers d'autres qui
n'étaient pas dans des réseaux mais qui
les ont aidés et qui ont risqué la
capture ou même d'être fusillé environ 2
2 ou 300 mille autres qui les ont té
décret les le peuple français c'est
quand même registre a résisté tout de
même aller mais il aura donné beaucoup
d'importance à ce cours elle a alors
bien sûr pour des raisons politiques
mais aussi morale alors vous parlez
aussi donc de l'épuration son refus de
gracier des écrivains collaborationniste
qui lui a été beaucoup reproché
notamment brasillach laval fusillé alors
qu'il était dans le coma
parce qu'il ait fait une tentative de
suicide il a voulu se suicider en
absorbant un poison qui était
partiellement périmés mais il serait
mort de toute façon on aurait pu le
laisser mourir
skali votre père soit là il y aurait
alors le maréchal pétain à votre père
voulait qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
condamnés
évidemment en sachant qu'il allait le
grâcier qu'ils ne laisseraient pas
fusillé mais il disait
si moi j'étais tombé dans les mains de
vichy il aurait pas eu autant de
clémence avec moi incontestablement il
aurait tout de suite été fusil et
d'ailleurs et les allemands ne leur est
exigé
ouais oui ce qui fait qu'ils ont fait
deux procès successifs ray ils ont
d'abord réduit au grade de colonel et là
et à une amende
et puis sans doute les allemands at il
protesté et un mois après ils ont réuni
un conseil de guerre qui à ce moment-là
l'a condamné à mort est la confiscation
de ses biens ray et à la perte de sa
nationalité
donc il l'aurait fusillé alors que lui
n'a pas fait fusiller pétarade août à
l'île d'yeu ouais
souvent quand on parle en france des
américains et de l'anti américanisme on
se réfère au général de gaulle et
j'attends une phrase dans votre livre
qui est finalement assez d'actualité
aujourd'hui
est-ce que
c'est ne pas aimer les américains de
considérer qu'ils n'ont pas à décider
pour la france dont chaque pays défendre
son peuple ses intérêts qui sont pas les
mêmes il faut rappeler ce que le papier
que les états unis remettait à chaque
soldat américain qui débarquait en
france etc et qui était intitulé vous
n'êtes pas là pour libérer la france
mais pour combattre un ennemi des états
unis ouais ouais
même si vous libérer la france c'est pas
le but de fait tous les français même
ceux qui ont libéré les états unis en
1786 au temps des guerres d'amérique
sont morts en réalité pour la france
pour le roi qui le représentait à
l'époque comme les américains les
soldats américains qui ont été tués sont
morts pour les états unis d'amérique et
les français pour la france c'est tout
chacun a ses intérêts et sa personnalité
propre à défendre aussi il faut voir que
les journalistes souvent parce que ça
faisait de la copie exagérait les
différends qui pouvait y avoir même s'il
y avait des différences fondamentales y
en avait c'est bien bien sûr j'ai états
unis étaient à leur place chez nous à la
nôtre est-ce que l'attitude de la france
face à la guerre d'irak vous semble dans
la ligne gaullienne de votre père très
certainement certainement mon père se
serait d'abord demandé qu avons nous
affaire dans ce pays en étant donné que
nous ne pouvons rien réglé nous français
il s'agit de nous français il s'agit pas
des autres donc le gaullisme perdure
d'une certaine façon le gaulliste
perdure alors n'y en a qui voudrait
qu'il ne perdure pas durer il perdu en
tous les cas oui alors à l'époque où
votre père est parti pour londres
évidemment l'opinion publique était
favorable à pétain il a décidé lui
d'incarner tout seul la résistance face
aux nazis
à votre avis aujourd'hui contre quoi
devons-nous résister contre la décadence
la peur contre la perte de confiance en
nous mêmes
mon père écrivait la france vient du
fond des âges
elle vit les siècles l'appel et quelle
que soit la situation
elles restent elles mêmes donc la france
qui tombe pour vous ça se corrige et
celles qui se laisse aller ouais
d'accord alors à l'époque de radio
londres on disait les français parlent
aux français
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que les français
devraient dire aux français a il faut
pas se laisser aller au déclin mais faut
toujours garder
l'avenir n'est jamais inéluctable après
les choses les choses ne sont pas on ne
peut pas savoir trois ans quatre ans
cinq ans après ce qui va se passer les
choses ne sont pas réglées davance une
fois pour toute c'est l'histoire et il
n'y a pas de sens de l'histoire ce n'est
pas vrai c'est une fausse théorie qui
était une doctrine mais une doctrine
très anciennement alors vous n'êtes pas
désespérer sérieusement aujourd'hui de
voir qu'en france y a pas d'homme
politique de l'envergure de la stature
de votre père tout le monde peut pas
être le général de gaulle c'est ce que
disait georges pompidou quand il lui a
succédé un jour m'invitant à dîner la
seule fois où il met invitait d'ailleurs
après mon père plusieurs années il m'a
dit qu'est ce que vous voulez je fais
comme je peux je ne suis pas le général
de gaulle d'un oui il n'est pas le
général de gaulle les chinois m'ont dit
un personnage comme votre père il y en a
un tous les siècles où tous les deux
siècles dans chaque pays
alors on a beaucoup de parler de votre
père philippe de gaulle
j'aimerais avant nous séparait candidats
mot sur votre fils qui s'appelle charles
de gaulle qui est au front national
de gaulle et le pen sur la même affiche
ça vous fait quoi on monfils l'âge du
premier ministre son grand père est mort
il ya trente trois ans et on n'accuse
pas d'autre chose d'autre
la faire et c'est à lui de voir
c'est son affaire ça vous a désolé ça ne
m'entraînais pas sur ce sujet je vous
répondrai pas ouais il est majeur et
vacciné
merci merci d'avoir été prévu a ajouté
quelque chose pour les plus jeunes qui
nous entende on représente trop souvent
le général de gaulle comme un dinosaure
way or personne ne sait plus adaptée à
son temps au temps qu'il avait il a
connu trois cultures trois civilisations
que le général de gaulle et il faut que
tous ceux qui sont ici autour se
souviennent que l'inventeur et lé
incitateur l'organisateur de la sécurité
sociale un des assedic c'est lui valent
des femmes
le vote des femmes est aussi le régime
bilité de la même façon que les sommes
dues le texte est que quand il monte
dans un tgv c'est le choix du général de
gaulle il a choisi le tgv contre le
turbo train ou le train à coussin d'air
le concorde c'est le général de gaulle
la airs l'airbus qui s'appelait aéro bus
super caravelle et caravelles celle
général de gaulle
le nucléaire c'est le général de gaulle
le périphérique autour de paris et les
autoroutes c'est le général de gaulle 1
alors voilà pour le passé en réalité le
général de gaulle et dernière merci
beaucoup merci si diego
le volontaire
entretien
c'était
c'est bon
[Musique]
question que je suis juste différent
[Applaudissements]
jamais la lâcher attendez je vais te
présenter ça va venir je vous présente
jamais debout au mieux par exemple ça va
mieux je connais tous vos sens et
remporte ou les rompre justice vient pas
juste gérer alors qu'elles coûtent moins
de questions le fait là ouais comme je
sais que tu as beaucoup de boulot hein
tu travaille comme un forcené c'est vrai
j'ai préparé très intéressant long à
lire on prend son temps
oui enfin prendre son temps évidemment
c'est parce que j'aurai comme j'ai pas
le temps moi c'est pour ça je vous
laisse tirer lire il me racontait hier
il regarde tout le monde en parle pour
savoir ce qui est dans les faits c'est
tout va donc très bien organisée en tout
cas observés pour radio longtemps j'ai
kiffé si je vous ai déjà dit et d'appel
du 18 juin comme je suis né le 18 juin
ça me fait kiffer ses partisans à
travers charles de gaulle étoile en
personne rien à dire j'ai eu à quelqu'un
alors j'étais en train de tirer en
testant que moi voilà moi je te décris
les questions pourquoi que tu perds ton
temps tu m'as fait des questions quant
aux parents avec de me poser des
questions à la con du style tromper csu
s'est encore fait peur je me mélange
fait comme si j'étais pas au courant des
questions
bon vous restait cinq minutes avec nous
je vous remercie surtout benjam elle
qu'est ce que vous faites là n'entend
jamais avant chanel
bon j'en ai qui se battent je respire
jamais baja mail à oui je crois que
c'était benjam elle
[Applaudissements]
ils sont tombés sans embûche permettre
d'en laure djamen on y va jamel bonsoir
bonsoir thiery alors jamel c'est
vraiment un honneur un immense privilège
d'avoir l'honneur de vous avoir ce soir
parmi nous après ces immenses triomphe
que vous avez accumulés ces quatre
dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui dans les acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
djamel si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est
ce que ça vous fait aujourd'hui à moins
de 30 ans de vous retrouver au panthéon
des acteurs français
[Applaudissements]
répéter la question parce que oui le
panthéon c'est la fin on lui
là encore 30 ans il a beaucoup de choses
à faire l'achat alors que jamais c'est
vraiment un honneur à l'immense
privilège d'avoir l'honneur de vous
avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui dans les acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est ce que
ça fait aujourd'hui de vous retrouver au
panthéon des acteurs français
je sais pas surtout dire ça comme ça
ouais je sais pas si risqué panthéon ou
arc de triomphe tour eiffel gens rien à
[ __ ] c'est plus difficile c'est pas
moi c'est les jo si les autres qui vont
au moins une certaine un vague
extraordinaire moi je subis plus tu vois
je suis pas trop grande je fais je fais
les choses naturellement passé c'est le
style c'est le style c'est clair
pourtant djamel d'après le journal de
mickey vous êtes l'acteur préféré les
enfants je tiens à remercier les enfants
en particulier pour pour ça c'est vrai
et c'est jouer ça s'est joué à ça entre
moi et plus tôt et c'est vrai qu'entre
un chien débile il a rappelé qu'à la
classe et autres furets
[Applaudissements]
jamel jamel c'est quoi vos plus grandes
qualités à part bien sûr la bogossité la
générosité la même minute est sale et
iris est très difficile de parler de soi
ouais j'ai envie de dire là la modestie
oui oui oui modestie c'est bien aussi si
ça fait deux ans de gens modestes
extrait modèle spécifique de gaulle
alors alors est ce qu'il vend des livres
c'est incroyable il faut vingt mille
livres par jour vous savez que c'est une
énorme le avant de 500000 la première en
point son effigie et des communes des
aéroports de métro voici mois ci ses
amis ouais c'est ça qui va faire beau si
un jour il ya des galères porte
s'appelle le jamel debbouzze commenge
quivrin stephen j
[Applaudissements]
m
imagine tu imagines si philippe de
gaulle premier du pognon sur charles de
gaulle roissy charles de gaulle étoile
station charles de gaulle il faut il
pour s acheter plein de cravate bordeaux
alors jamel en 2002 d'après le figaro
vous êtes devenu l'acteur français le
mieux payé
oui mais d'ailleurs ça va causer pas mal
de temps je dois parce que maintenant
j'ai je vois venir plein de nouveaux
cousins qui sont en galère d'oseille
qu'il débarque comme ça il ya encore
rien mais qui est venu me voir en disant
je suis le fils de ton père tu dis donc
ça voudrait dire qu'il serait mon frère
m'a dit ouais je suis ton frère je
t'aime mon fils veut rien dire du tout
passé à cause du figaro qui en pleine
crise d'identité alors ouais
effectivement il faut
j'aimerais remercier le figaro pour cet
article de bata bon djamel alors c'est
votre grand retour sur scène en décembre
vous êtes venus ici pour en parler merci
pas du tout irait chevillon toute amitié
alors je vais pas venu faire de la promo
bombe c'est vrai que c'est mon grand
retour sur scène en même temps faut
faire un petit peu je joue au bataclan
une femme à partir du 23 décembre
jusqu'au 11 janvier
c'est quasi l'otarie battre à décembre
jusqu'au 11 janvier au casino de paris
après j'enchaîne avec le bataclan 10 13
au 18 janvier après c'est vrai que
l'olympia arrive le 20 janvier jusqu'à
ce que mort s'ensuive
c'est pas venu pour en parler
véritablement je te tue pas la question
et si vous voulez louer les places c'est
à la fnac ou virgin
[Applaudissements]
le nouveau spectacle de jamel c'est quoi
le spectacle ça va s'appeler djamel 100%
debbouze et pourquoi parce que je
m'appelle jamel debbouze a baissé une
bonne sinon je rappelais différemment
[Applaudissements]
jamais vous pouvez me dire en deux mots
de quoi ça parle de moi à de vous c'est
pour ça que ça s'appelle djamel 100%
debbouze en fin de mois birsa en
plusieurs mois j'aurais fait j'aurais
dit autre chose mais là maintenant pas
voilà enfin venir voir le spectacle pour
savoir ne placez pas ça parle uniquement
de moi pourquoi ça s'appelle l'église et
de causticité à son paroxysme de
questions qui sévit dans le temps cc
c'est souvent prendre dans mon premier
spectacle je racontais un petit peu
j'étais très surpris de faire ce métier
avec tout ce que ça implique et est
maintenant ndlr que je suis vraiment
dedans c'est encore plus étonnant c'est
ce que je raconte ce que je vais tâcher
de raconter vous croyez que ça va
intéresser les gens
c'est pas parce que tu crois que pour
décor de merde il intéresse les gens
[Applaudissements]
faire pour venir te voir avec l'émission
ultime demande si ça va intéresser les
gens tu crois pas franchement sever et
les pourris et ces tags sais pas qui
c'est ta grand-mère café cedao ses
valises il s'élargit et d'adressé darty
musique les tags sortir ils sont il est
anti musique ont fait l'état grec il
devait être sous jb c'est impossible je
vais te montrer ce que c'est que de
taguer exactement je vais faire venir
des amis à moi au prat montrer ce que
c'est que détail quand tu t'inquiètes
pas encore encore une question que je
bouge maintenant que vous avez un succès
énorme que vous croulez sous les
sollicitations
vous pouvez nous dire est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper tu vois qu'il veut battre
en empêcher toujours ce qu'elle veut
profondément sadique
tu dois tu dois être honnête il doit
être fait tout ans a dit si tu essaies
tu t'es pas obligé de me poser la
question est ce que 6,6 et remplacé par
mmc toutes les stars je ne peux pas te
répondre à cette question je préfère me
taire la mère regarde l'émission un peu
c'est ramadan chez tag jamel
est-ce que tant qu'il est là c'est
incroyable de laval va revenir au mois
de février philippe de gaulle mais est
ce qu est ce que tu as une question à
lui poser
philippe de gaulle vous êtes donc le
fils forcément de charles est ce que il
aimer le rap est ce qu'ils connaissaient
tupac shakur biggie smalls par exemple
de son temps ça fait pas comme ça et il
lui arrivait de danse et de partir en
vrille ou par branches et non mais
regardez les gens dansaient mais jamais
jamais voulait prendre pris en flag dans
votre salon en train de la même jamais
non jamais jamais le sang est épuisé il
était très strict
carpostal non c'est pas ça mais comme ce
n'était pas dans son talent il préférait
regarder ceux dont le talent mais parce
qu'on voit les chefs d'état en aide
de mon point de vue en tout cas je suis
pas chef d'état que de mon état je me
dis que healy ils sont toujours obligés
tout le temps toute leur vie d'être
sérieux oui sans vous rien de sérieux
mais ça les empêche pas de s'amuser
parfois mais c'est un jeu ce soir et à
tout moment quand même s'ils sont pas un
sourire et qu'on ne les voit pas rire il
ya des choses qui les amuse il n'a
jamais touvé touche d'expérience des
frères étant il est il était plutôt
gentil plus tôt et tout sage plutôt
chefs d'état et les gentilles et état il
avait à faire à vos difficultés et
forcément il n'y avait pas que ça ferme
abstrait par on l'avait fait venir pour
ça ouais non ça c'était un peu aller
chercher chercher dans tout ça comme on
dit chez moi
merci beaucoup merci vive le vol
le bol mon père philippe devaux
l'entretien avec michel tauriac
[Musique]
les
à
et
mais
conte
[Musique]
c
chanter
la revenir en février pour le deuxième
tome alors le spectacle donc c'est
d'abord au casino de paris c'est ça
ensuite au bataclan ensuite à l'olympia
c'est ça carla et c'est avec kader aoun
toujours tu l'écris avec kader et c'est
kader qui fait la mise en scène toujours
cela ne change pas une équipe qui gagne
on a fait ça son premier spectacle vrai
que ça fonctionne et qu'on a pris
beaucoup de plaisir et je vois pas
pourquoi je changerai mon algérienne
pour rien au monde je la lâche pas je la
kiffe raider si tu m'écoutes change rien
kader si tu m'écoutes changerait de la
chance de travailler avec kader aoun
cette façon je suis travailleur très
content pour kader avant toute chose
c'est vrai que c'est un mec parce que ce
que j'aime beaucoup chez lui c'est que
il vient du des mêmes endroits que moi
et vient de bobigny et et à la
différence de moi il a fait sciences po
et c'est ce qui lui permet d'avoir un
certain recul sur bobigny et je suis
riche de ses de son expérience à chaque
fois il fait profiter de tout ce qu'il
connaît et il a lu plein de bouquins que
j'ai pas eu forcément donc il me fait la
syntaxe tout temps il a lu tous les
livres il a vu tous les films et toutes
les émissions vont se régler chez comme
si j'avais fait sciences po quelque part
tu as vu ce que m'a offert hélène ségara
le problème c'est qu'on l'arrêté ap
voilà ça c'est celle m segarra quitte à
en faire ça oui elle m'a offert aussi
des du foie gras mais le foie gras était
pas là et devrait s'inspirer du rat
musqué ça lui ferait vendre plus de
disques a reçu ouais on va en parler à
orlando
adam
jackman
là-bas au jeu
et maintenant que flash jeter leurs noms
une brouille
il faut une petite poule rousse jeunes m
quel si michel l'anc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà
comment elle est belle c'est vrai on
peut pas dire le contraire en faisant
observer tous les deux vous avez des
super surtout à michel tu peux pas dire
des trucs comme ça gratuit tu me dises à
moi forcément après je vais avoir envie
qui se passe quelque chose entre nous
mais moi je sais ça y est depuis
longtemps cherché à chaque fois qu'on se
voit sur un plateau de télé michèle
laroque
on se dit qu'on va se revoir sans les
caméras après toi tu pars los angeles
moi je fais toutes mes émissions se voit
pas alors si on n'était pas à la télé tu
me dire et you tu me direz vous bon ben
je t'ai dis tu ouais
est ce que si on n'était pas à la télé
tu serais aussi heureuse de voir que ce
soir c'est déjà arrivé
oui oui mais pas assez je trouve est ce
que tu te serais fait aussi belle si on
n'était pas la télé pour m'avoir mais
j'ai toujours vu moi aussi
resplendissante seul soleil
[Applaudissements]
j'étais pas la télé toute petite tu te
serais laissé faire par exemple on fait
quoi ça a été baladé on irait boire un
verre on inverse têtu que des plats
l'endroit super où elle a de la
bouteille qui est sous toi tu crois que
tu vas lui faire à l'envers à elle
connaît par coeur ça fait trente neuf
ans 3,3 ce métier bien c'est plus moi
michel g merdier sur cela je veux aller
prendre un café en attendant je suis
désolé je ne vais pas dire ça oui mais
est-ce que sur l'été pas la télé michel
tu me dirait vraiment ce que tu penses
le mois mais oui moi je connais un
thierry ardisson que j'adore parce qu'on
est double ouais et que et que et avec
beaucoup de sensibilité de gentillesse
et d'intelligence et je le pense et
qu'il ya un os thierry ardisson tab on
connaît pas que j'aie jamais rencontré
vraiment dont parfois on parle parfois
et j'espère que celui que je connais va
complètement voilà chacun thierry
ardisson tu étais pas la télé je
pourrais te je crois être dragués marié
tu étais majesty sérieuse alors soit il
par la télé on parlait de ton actu tu
crois qu'on n'en parlerait pas en fait
si on était passé n'était pas été on ne
part pas d'en parler parce qu'on
annonçait ce que tu t'intéresses à tout
ce que je fais dans tu me donnerait
alors non j'aurais bien sûr en arrivant
je pense que je te demanderai de trois
questions
on me donnait une con d'accord je crois
que alex reeves
je crois que les mecs qu'ils ont décidé
oui mais qu'est ce que ça va intéresser
le public mon spectacle
ouais tu vas voir qu'après cette
émission pour décor il va intéresser le
public
[Applaudissements]
djamel sait nous toucher j'ai dit non
mais non mais toi fais comme si de rien
n'était vous continuez vos émissions
allez-y alesi un yves à aucun prix de
diane a un problème il n'a pas un caméra
oui 4 je pense que ma veste et qu'il l'a
pas fait nous comptons sur lui rendent
bien
il revient à tanit et l'oeil de
freestyle c'est le mec de blanc dit tu
sais pas je suis désolé s'est quittés
potes qui sont avec toi la bdd est
repris de justesse et sociaux
[Applaudissements]
je continue alors messieurs youtube à
michal qui va tourner dans [ __ ] dure
dans wii avec d'armand dutronc dany boon
a exactement mais je crois qu'on va
beaucoup s'amuser et dany boon tu l'as
tu l'as vu sept ans sinon la dernière
fois que je les ai vus j'ai pas vu sa
pièce mais je vais y aller mais alors
passé il était en vacances à megève il a
aidé voilà il avait l'air en forme et
j'ai remis de sa séparation d'avec
judith parce qu'elle était la semaine
dernière bell a l'air de s'être bien
remise et je pensais incinération lui
aussi se mettre hors la loi
[Applaudissements]
franchement c'est un michael sheen une
même thierry à majeur sinon sa vie
catherine me demande si on peut aller
chercher une veste de secours chez moi
catherine
mais si je donne le code comme je fais
une autre émission chez moi tu donnes le
code que trine c'est mort c'est dommage
que philippe de gaulle soit parti yona
jalabert honoré qui fait faire philippe
de gaulle nous ce racket des malades
c'est sûr tiens donc
judith godrèche et elle à la semaine de
la semaine dernière elle avait l'air
d'avoir assez bien appris sa séparation
d'avec dany boon ça allait nettement
mieux et gagner ça va aussi
mais j'ai l'impression les repas sans
terre pour un non alors il ya aussi un
coffret qui va sortir avec ils s'aiment
ils 66 minutes voilà avec pierre il se
fait engueuler noms soient rouverts les
caméras avec caméra jamais oui camping
près qui sort alors des kits somme ils
se sentent eux mais voilà c'est ça la
saga complète tu penses tu fais quoi
michel quand tu pars tout le temps à los
angeles comme ça alors moi je prépare un
film j'ai acheté les droits d'un livre
qui s'appelle pitch de caroline bong
rome je le connais voilà c'est bien sûr
et on voudrait faire un film inspiré de
ce livre as tu vas faire un film sauvez
le pitch peut-être alors tu vas venir le
pitch est ici un max obligatoire oui
alors je n'étais pas à la télé ce que je
pourrais couper les moments où j'ai
l'air con quand je te regarde comme ça
jamais l'air con c'est vrai oui c'est
une idée que tu te fais tu
m'impressionnes ce n'était pas la télé
tu dirais quoi du décor de cette
émission
franchement il ya un truc que j'aime
beaucoup c'est la veste mais vraiment
pas qui ça sert je trouve que c'est
qu'est ce t'en penses non un petit truc
si je manque un tout petit truc je vais
la signer way up
ouais
sur place
sinclair pharma laisse comme un délit
peut venir la balayer sa part commence
sur la peau pas vraiment ouais soit là
je suis comme ça pour un long moment
est ce qu'on peut faire valérie et
lingettes et l'os est là revient avec
des lingettes vallée riche quand ils les
interviews de madame laroque
je termine ici alors je n'étais pas la
télé tu aurais quoi comme problème à me
raconter je sais pas ce qu'il ya eu dans
le ciel les ars et cetera que les gens
qui étaient un peu fragiles sont allées
très très très mal ouais et j'avais
plein de coups de fil de gens qui
allaient mal et ça m'a vraiment inquiété
voilà c'est ça les problèmes
entraînements mais c'est jean-philippe
un peu en ce moment c'est la période de
l'année
bachy non plus une époque un petit peu
c'est ça ouais ouais et puis comme je
suis maintenant entre les deux c'est
quand je reviens je sens plus ces choses
parce que j'ai pas subi tu vois toutes
les pressions ici et je trouve que
parfois c'est très lourd
et si je trouve que les gens sont plus
flipper enfin aux états unis en france
c'est différent ils sont entrés ils
pullulent sommes pas d'accord avec vous
je chante mais à cause de bushmills non
mais les gens n'ont plus le moral
il ya eu quelque chose ou est de 12 je
trouve un truc ce sont des gens plus la
pêche non qu'est ce qui se passe là-bas
0.4 il dit mais dans la loge vip
d'accord ok je viens d'assister une
chose extraordinaire ici j'espère que ta
famille un costume n'a annoncé louis b
je sais aussi comment des quotas m c'est
par amour rien jouer thierry
total chic type ben c'est pas moi ah ça
y est
[Applaudissements]
il s'est enfui il s'est enfui à le janet
dia si quelqu'un pouvait maîtriser jamel
debbouze si la personne n'a agi de
questions à poser à tirer directement
temps je t'entends djamel comment tu
peux mettre des photos pareil sérieux
quoi qui as
mais david valider la cua rien mauvaise
mise sur cette photo mais c'est le style
de la photo djamel troll pas le choc
d'apprendre à à dire que mon spectacle
n'est pas intéressant bouffon
alors monsieur si on n'était pas la
télévision
même s'ils n'étaient pas la télévision
est ce que tu me parlerait quand même de
gerpinnes teurs ouais ouais c'est bien
c'est bien celui-ci l'avait bien content
pour lui parce que c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de talent et
j'adore le spectacle qui fait les gens
mais ce martèlement et voilà quoi c'est
sait quelque chose
il a été longtemps un to lose it arrivée
à paris là tout ça leur lui a pas encore
la pression et s'excuser sur wii
l'impression qui nous attend exactement
il y croit vraiment et je trouve que
c'est bien et alors il est venu ici nous
parler de son nouveau spectacle qui
s'appelle on tire bien sûr les lapins au
théâtre fontaine tu l'as vu évidemment
rien ça fait marrer et match ils adorent
et ma mère elle adore tu vois c'est un
peu tout génération doit bientôt mais en
fait super bien j'ai en pin teurs on
tire bien sûr les lapins mariétou
[Musique]
c'est un chien c'est sûr que sans les
poils
stop de naphtaline
staline et ses buildings
cet effort le chien ne sont pas
deuxièmes c'est le chien réversible mais
ça fait donc la carte
[Musique]
mpk
les pompiers allaient papier ah ben ça
c'est encore pire
non c'est plus compliqué les papilles et
un commerce avant pour les familles les
entités c'était facile moyer puis
bagages on me sert cosy il est tout
petit et tous mes chances qu'iliad
[Musique]
luffy et qu'elle était l'onglet jetons
voilà j'ai enfin terme au duc et j'en
avec nos terres on tire bien sûr les
lapins au théâtre fontaine avec le
soutien de michèle laroque est notre
invité ce soir
[Applaudissements]
ah c'est ma nouvelle musique de bonheur
ça allait bien
c'est ma nouvelle musique de mahler
alors vous savez michèle laroque qu'on a
fait une étude à temps qu'est-ce qui se
passe non non non non non non
sérieusement écoute moi en valais on va
lui amener une veste quatre d'entre
elles laissent pas faire un docteur
kiffer quel prix on est avec toi
attends attends attends attends les prix
internet deux minutes pour nous mais je
te plains public attend ça avec défi
jeunes balaj je compte des filles je te
pince ans et j'arrête je te parle t on
pas assez sévères
bien et ben voilà donc un trinh barma
catherine barma
elle est aussi patent jamel debbouze
alors michel vous savez qu'à une étude
de popularité qui a été fait par un
institut qui s'appelle sin études et qui
vient de vous attribuer le titre
d'actrice la plus populaire de france
alors sept à mix entre la notoriété et
la côte d'amour et c'est vous alors
évidemment on va vous faire une
interview qui s'appelle l'actrice la
plus populaire de france
alors michel ça vous surprendre avec
l'actrice la plus populaire de france où
vous trouvez ça normal
non ça me surprend et ça me fait c'est
pas normal du tout non non je trouve que
c'est attendu très bas pour moi il ya
longtemps vous êtes la plus populaire
dans mon coeur mais là franchement je
suis content alors est ce que vous avez
commencé à vous la péter un peu oui oui
ça non je souhaitais je sais pas
franchement je me la pète pas ça qui est
bien chez michel je ne sais pas vous
allez augmenter vos prix quand même je
crois pas c'est pas le moment
d'augmenter ses prix en france ouais
mais non et est ce que vous allez
continuer à traîner un boulet comme
pierre palmade derrière vous aux
artistes et j'espère je vais le traîner
toute ma vie vous allez garder la classe
dans votre cv
j'assume tout non c'était important à ce
moment là tu es complètement débutante
j'avais adapté d'une pièce de théâtre et
on personne ne me connaissait je voulais
faire venir les gens tat les gens sont
venus
tu peux pas vous garder la classe g
garde tout ce que j'ai fait les fesses
borloo oui je garde tout alors je vous
fais pas chier toujours la meilleure
quand même je suis pas que j'en avais
hier non parce que justement comme
j'étais justement on a parlé déjà mon
enfance où j'ai fait plein de trucs
j'étais jamais la meilleure parce que çà
et là pour une fois c'est bon quand même
dix ans parce que je suis la preuve
voilà michèle laroque qui soutient le
spectacle de jean peeters on tient bien
sûr la femme s'est fait théâtre fontaine
avec mme kuchel gens avec la carte des
germes yzerman
[Musique]
et maintenant
je serai là
[Musique]
une seule
voici maria pacôme
[Musique]
maria pacôme bonsoir soir
parce que tu disais je pouvais pas tu le
prennes man tu le savais j'ai reçu
voulait qu'un seul tu penses à navès
djamel ouais tu avais pas quittés
enfin ceci étant le décor il est mieux
depuis que tu l'as nick et moi aussi je
traverse tout de suite oui si tu
pourrais pas partir alors marié atteint
comme rebond soir alors je vois
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus roger hart
qui vous habille et donald cardwell kivu
décor vous êtes plutôt habillé comme un
cas comme un journaliste un journaliste
en irak the line baisse de 2 sont un
succès particulièrement des petits
gilets mois correspondants de guerre un
petit peu là le look ça va maria très
bien et bien alors donc j'étais à la
fiche de mauvais esprit de patrick
alessandrin avec thierry lhermitte
ophélie winter clémentine célarié michel
muller je cite l'attaché de presse est
toujours inscrite gavard je sais pas si
elle est en coulisses catherine laurence
astrid et la dent qu'astrid surveille et
si des fois je parlais pas c'est bien du
du film mauvais esprit tu pourrais venir
voilà alors oui sûrement
elle est charmant nadal c'est que
c'était mon assistante astres et oui
mais je sais tu dis on a vu avec la
gaule du matin
elle n'avait pas dit ça on peut vous
dire en tous les cas que je l' ai
toujours respectés à elle m'a pas dit ça
non plus alors le pitch bah écoutez
c'est très simple clic sur les esprits
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui n'a
vraiment pas de pot dans la vie qui est
incarné par michel muller jusqu'au jour
où il meurt renversé par une voiture
conduite par thierry lhermitte et il va
renaître dans la peau du bébé que
thierry lhermitte va avoir avec ophélie
winter et il est prêt à tout pour se
venger bref c'est une espèce de chien
orné comme on dit sur les affiches du
film c'est une excellente idée de
vraiment c'est un film très bonne idée
c'est le genre de scénarii que les
américains nous rachète en général parce
que c'est vraiment c'est très fort la
réincarnation du sieur dans le bébé
alors évidemment chaque fois qu'il voit
thierry lhermitte tu le détestes vomi
dessus alors alessandra avait déjà fait
15 août que tu as un bon film 15 8 et 13
août il est aujourd'hui toujours des
bonnes idées
alors vous vous êtes la mer donc de
thierry lhermitte la belle-mère
d'ophélie winter et vous êtes appelés à
un moment à la rescousse pour contrôler
cet affreux bébé oui enfin un monstre
vaughan bien oui les deux monstres est
d'ailleurs oui il ya trois mois il ya le
petit alors qu'en fait c'est ça qu'est
ma tante et d'ailleurs qui m'a fait que
vraiment ophélie winter
c'est une horreur là moi je suis une
horreur on se traite mais comme une
vraiment c'est assez vrai c'est vrai
qu'à l'est des rapports n'ya pas y'a pas
sourire las des rapports d'une violence
entre winter et vous
elmer il n'existe pas jamais non jamais
ça moi je connais pas très très violent
c'est très très violent mais alors on va
regarder à quoi ça ressemble plus on en
parle
mariétou un homme d'affaires c'était un
garçon à l'artiste
incompris
on met vraiment travail vous devez
réparation dégagé s'il vous plaît
jusqu'au jour la chance les secours
arrivent je savais très bien sacré vol
plané 1
je vous dit il se réincarnant bébé et à
lui mon papa à je vais t'en faire baver
mon papa ça y est les reculs et
j'attends vos et de dire comment ça dodo
détection de la cible l'accrochage est
un roman mais le strict en plein dans la
peau du héros c'est très bon pour la
poubelle bien qu'en lan ou la patate
aime bien pour notre san mames heures au
bon dieu sait quoi ce monde qu'il est ok
les vieilles quoi vous vous en moquez
plaisir une belle gueule oui si vous
avez un nivellement et comme vous êtes
sans vous parler fort ma petite fille
j'ai élevé les enfants vous dépêcher
d'en vivre ça à [ __ ] dans mermet
j'ai retenté bible et les vues en juger
par jour et prendre une voiture de plein
fouet
vous avez sa potée de l'andorre bien sûr
mais ça j'ai toujours dit qu'il ne
fallait pas confier notre enfant et un
vieillard sénile et hargneuse le
flambeau de vie à dieu aliens je
reviendrai je m'ouvre un site arrivé
quelque chose tout ça mais c'est
peut-être ça la solution l'accident
domestique sera trop chute
c'est pas beau ça va saigner
quoi
dommage plutôt tentées redescend gens me
restait de patrick alessandrin avec tes
amis te finir une pierre michel muller
et maria pacôme et notre invité ce soir
voilà alors est-ce que l'astre idée
qu'on tente un strict 10 mois elle est
contente c'est un sourire astres et
willy rassuré on connaît sa valeur si je
fais un str il est content tout content
là les connaît bien
alors vous maria pacôme donc dans si
vous n'êtes pas comme est ce qu en
diable vous êtes là belle-mère foldingue
quoi voilà une fois de plus folle dingue
non
fientes méchante mais pas folle dingue
paul lafargue c'est une méchante femme
il réussit même pas sa belle-fille l
alliance on peut même son le petit bébé
elle n'a dormi méchamment elle dit à un
moment oui bon ça va
faut pas faire chier en carriole à lyon
foot anglais elle est vraiment odieuse
vous êtes un petit peu quand même là la
barre joue dans ce film même si vous
l'êtes moins que que vous l'avez été oui
j'en étais là c'est d'ailleurs je me
suis arrêté qu'en guise et c'est pour ça
que vous êtes devenu auteur c'est parce
qu'avant vous en aviez marre de faire ce
à quoi le
voilà vous avez compris que les pièces
que vous écriviez t'es pas pire que
celle qu'on vous apporter ces thèmes
alors qu'ils avaient déjà il ya des
pièces bien meilleure mais apprendriez
voilà et en plus vous avez découvert que
quand on touche les droits d'auteur
c'est plus sympa c'est surtout ça qui
était d'ailleurs ça a été très agréable
très très agréable mais très marias de
bois de pognon mais qu'est ce qu'il
raconte comme imbécillité là où bien sûr
que non j'aimerais beaucoup de ça
j'avais de quoi vous arrêter de
travailler quand même j'y pense de ce
nom mais je pense là oui on va piquer
ton ton pognon mais en fait ce qui est
terrible et maria pacôme et ça arrive
souvent avec les avec les grands acteurs
c'est que vous avez été bon j'ai fait
une carrière formidable vous avez
réjouit nombre de fois et en fait votre
rêve secret c'était de jouer tchekhov
cette fameuse cette fameuse phrase que
vous adorez ne me soukous et pas comme
ça je suis plein de larmes
oui dites le moi comme vous l'auriez dit
mes secrets pas comme ça je suis plein
de larmes
ouais voilà ce qu'on a raté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le théâtre n'est pas comme eux pendant
la guerre votre père a été déporté à
buchenwald et l époque vous êtes senti
d'un seul coup très seul trait libre et
vous vous êtes dirigés vers le vers le
théâtre au cours simon
vous dites plutôt au café d'à côté
d'ailleurs le phare oui oui n'ont jamais
été une femme d'aider des cours je crois
que je me suis faite toute seule comme
ça alors simon au cours simon vous a dit
t'es pas une beauté
mais entre garde désir quoi vous aviez
une présence oui c'est ça alors
histoire
je vois je vraiment ces moustiques
je vois que tu es tombé sur le sur le
même plan ouais je viens de te soutenir
ce que tu es un peu sol ça te va très
bien oh oui toi aussi je te regarder à
l'écran c'est bon c'est bien mais à un
moment donné c'est pénible mais c'est un
début de l'émission ça va mais quand il
veut être où il alors de la matin c'est
exact c'est que j'ai vu des trucs donc
pouvoir y raconte pas ce que voulait pas
vu j'ai vu monsieur de gaulle donc
l'amiral de gaulle un croisé gabriel
cohn bendit a weak abriel cohn bendit
lui a dit bonjour
gabriel cohn bendit il a tiqué le vieux
disque est drôle c'est que c'est des
rencontres par procuration ouais c'est
assez ordinaire de cohn bendit avec le
fils de 2 go oui voilà c'est ça qui est
marrant et lui il l'a ticket enfin en
fait donc son fish
mais non il a marqué le coup c'est
rigolo alors c'est que maria pacôme est
venu au théâtre dans la guerre sans père
était déporté à buchenwald et qu'elle
allait au cours simon enfin plutôt à
côté du court ciment dans un district
s'appelle le village mais alors si
mentalement c'est mieux en face d'accord
et simon lui a dit cette phrase
mémorable tu n'es pas une beauté
mais entre garde ce qui veut dire que
tout de suite il avait vu que vous aviez
une présence quoi peut-être moi un peu
pour me flageller qui rajoutait tu n'es
pas une beauté relation dure ça peut
paraître un peu excessif
il a dit voir mais tu as une présence
maria a un moment faut arrêter de s'auto
flageller ça va on va l'amener vrai je
suis d'accord même pas déconner alors
évidemment ce n'est pas beaucoup
d'argent à l'époque et simon vous a dit
toujours lui le cours simon
tu peux pas payer mais tu as une gueule
tu laisses ta wii à la part ajouté mien
il a dit non parce que je suis le seul à
dire tu n'es pas une beauté brute tu vas
pas d'ailleurs donc ne sera pas une
bouteille tu vas pas péché d'orgueil tu
restes tu vois il avait je crois qu'il
avait confiance en moi même s'ils
voulaient que je travaillais pas
beaucoup il a dit tu restes et vous êtes
resté je suis parti c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque vous aviez pas beaucoup
d'argent vous étiez soutien dont
continue d'ailleurs arrêtée là mais ce
n'est qu'à 16 ans à 16 ans s'est
récemment mariée à 16 ans vous étiez
apprenti chez un fabricant de chaussures
oui mais bien sûr j'ai présenté sa harpe
est à feu - là où il fallait bien
travailler parce que papa était dans la
rue quand on était tout jeune frère et
moi et que fallait voilà enfin du temps
et c'était un peu dur mais séduire trop
plein de chez huawei et c'est l'époque
où maria pacôme mon cher moustiques
étaient donc mancka visite des photos
publicitaires et à ce moment là donc
j'étais pas belle mais beaucoup des
mannequins volant c'est l'époque on peut
le dire je crois ce soir parce que la
prescription
vous avez failli un peu mal tourné à
l'époque non oui oui oui
une présence dans ce genre j'étais le
fait que mon père était arrêtée on était
des mômes et que j'étais un homme très
sévère le fait d'avoir cette liberté du
jour au lendemain est très dangereuse
parce que parce que d'avoir j'étais très
très bien élevés mais très durement
partir de là voilà et maintenant était
un peu faible
voilà donc j'ai eu la chance c'est de la
chance le théâtre le théâtre vous a
sauvé d'une vie dissolue maria pacôme je
sais mes rencontres ont sauvé beaucoup
plus mais entendre le teatro nomme ben
ouais et puis voilà cette histoire de
soutien de famille a duré toute votre
vie parce que vous avez toujours été
ensuite celle qui abritait le fric à la
maison à l'abri
évidemment ça vous amener à accepter des
rôles qui était pas obligatoirement ce
que vous espériez
adolescente je n'ai vraiment pas bon du
tout de ce que j'ai joué il ya jamais
une chose honteuse dans mais vraiment
quand tu t'es vraiment trop moche je
disais non je sais pas j'ai jamais et je
n'étais pas habité par le théâtre j'ai
jamais eu 13 en jeu j'aimais bien je
mets bien écrire je veux bien jouer
j'aimais bien la vie surtout si tôt que
j'avais gagné un que je gagnais afrique
que j'arrêtais très vite d'ailleurs et
je parte c'est de l'habillage foutait le
camp je dépense mon fric et je revenais
mon agent mais j'ai toujours mais tu
feras jamais de carrière mais je m'en
foutais moi et j'avais là cette chance
extraordinaire de retrouver tout de
suite quelque chose à faire est ce que
vous pensez sérieusement maria pacôme
que vous avez eu la carrière que vous
méritiez a été redonné flemmarde quand
je le suis et grillons us et c'est
vraiment c'est incohérent la manière
dont je vis c'est une suite une vraie
chance un jeu mérite pas cette carrière
je méritais pas mieux je regrette mais
moi moi je regrette de ne pas avoir fait
du cinéma mais avoir été voir des
metteurs en scène il fallait il faut le
faire sécheresse à se déplacer j'ai
jamais rien fait tout ce qui m'est
arrivé c'est arrivé et je crois que j'ai
du talent c'est pour ça donc ayant des
qualités bon ben j'ai surnager n'ya pas
commun en tout cas je sais pas si tu le
sais maria pacôme a été mariée avec
maurice ronet savez oui comme le plus
beau de tous n'étant pas une beauté
c'est une sanction
j'ai pu avoir le plus bel homme du
cinéma et on était très amoureux que
c'est l'été écoutez on était drôlement
mignons tous les deux étaient dingues de
vous maurice ronet vous imaginez le
nombre d'entre elles sont jalouses de
vous ce soir
alors ce qui est très marrant c'est qu'à
l'époque où jamais imaginé ça à l'époque
vous étiez avec maurice ronet vous étiez
un peu baba cool avant l'heure quoi vous
êtes parti dans le bouddhisme zen non
oui on a fait des choses insensées ont
été mutilés retrouver à moustiers sainte
marie et ont trouvé la la la la la
vieille terre pour refermer on a fait
des choses dingues
on leur en abandonner tous quitté
théâtre c'est fou c'est fou on était pas
on était tout un groupe là il y avait
des gens même un peu qui après peintre
tout ça on est le théâtre c'était bien
loin on voulait une autre vie relate
vous rêviez d'une autre vie et moi j'ai
commencé à être un peu connu j'avais 33
dans encore un petit peu avant mais ça
m'était complètement égal
j'avais envie de lui de faire des choses
comme ça c'est vrai que ça s'est terminé
en vendant de la lavande au bord des
routes ont en effet toutes mignonnes
alaoui avec une amie on avait j'avais
moi tâches et des morceaux de 2,2 de
tissus comme ça que tout à l'heure on
éteignait toutes les couleurs on s'est
dit et moi j'étais très à droite pour
faire ça on cueille de l'avant ne tue
pas mais tu es tout bronzé avec la les
deux jusqu'ici
et puis on arrêter les voitures ça fait
un fric fou avec sa reine on faisait des
trucs comme ça pour eux parce que c'est
pas cool avant l'heure ah oui ouais
alors missionné mois souvent je comprend
michèle laroque à elvire popesco parce
qu'elles sont roumaine toutes les deux
mais je crois que j'aurais pu aussi vous
comparez à maria pacôme michèle laroque
oh la la la la la
[Applaudissements]
femmes 1
on ne trouvait pas de groupe et on se
dit qu'un homme ça me ferait peut-être
plaisir c'est le seul truc que j'ai
réussi à table et a pas trouvé plus
grands noms mais bien à la hauteur du
talent de maria pacôme
je suis désolé maintenant mais je vais
la garder une veste peinte par jamel
debbouze up allait se classe elle l'a
une veste portugal de boules qui avait
tu devais être ridicule à l'antenne je
sais pas lequel les questions sérieuses
atteintes qu'elle en pense on en dire
autant dire toujours oui ce sont les
étudierai ça c'est bien ce que je
propose c'est pendant cette petite pause
on écoute huile de michèle laroque
choisi spécialement pour elle
[Musique]
c'est
oui
c'est lui que de michèle laroque lave
les cieux
valérie tu penses que tu arrives à plat
quelque chose
[Musique]
aussi
merci beaucoup avait besoin de son
physique est ce que ça vous voulez quand
le gars davantage du nord regarde c'est
ça aussi écoute bien gris bien
[Musique]
trois années là
l édition
[Musique]
j
j'ai ça aussi
[Musique]
ça c'est bon ça
toi
[Musique]
ça aussi
on
et voilà alors vous savez toi tu le sais
mais maria vous savez que jamel remonte
sur scène et la salle c'était un
événement quoi lui dis toujours un
événement effectivement quand est-ce que
tu remontes alors du 13e descendront au
18 décembre au casino de paris
ensuite janssoone du vin fin j'ai pas
l'exacte et date exacte mais c'est
casino de paris bataclan olympia et vous
êtes la première fois parce que je
l'aimais mme jouanno va n'a jamais le
100% debbouze donc je voulais profiter
de cette émission pour pau pour pour
faire une petite annonce mais ligne peut
venir de seconde ah oui alors c'est ses
mails il fit appel méline fait longtemps
que c'était comme ça mais sicilienne
sont vraiment ces mélina wild in may
line là alors je t'explique c'est une
basket que j'ai signé moi-même l'asse
écrit jamel debbouze ouais avec marc et
en arabe ici espoir et etc c'est parce
qu'il a dessinée oui c'est une basket
concocter des styles et les bénéfices de
cette basket sont destinés à aider les
enfants des rues au maroc par le biais
de l'association l'heure joyeuse et plus
en vendre plus on en vendra plus on
aidera des gosses qui sont défavorisés
pas seulement au maroc mais mais un peu
partout dans le monde et je voulais
faire un peu la publicité de cette
basket bon bien sûr elle s'appelle jamel
debbouze elle est extraordinaire et avec
moi le déchire sa mère cette paire de
pompes
j'ai exactement la même là whaou
un lancer la cible
je veux juste profiter de cette émission
pour dire qu'elle est en vente bientôt
je vous en supplie acheter là
moi
m
là
canal ne bouge je vais être obligée d'y
aller parce que j'ai des courses à faire
ouais c'est que c'est madame rama dont
il faut que j'aille acheter deux rivales
l'aise la bia du mark en route
et si j'ai pas mal dans les magasins
vont bientôt être fermé d'asie c'est
quand tu veux je j'ai adoré cette
émission il ya logiquement on peut
[ __ ] le bordel comme ça c'est toujours
un plaisir et en plus tout le bordel
mieux je me crois
[Musique]
il
bien remarquez bien là où va très bien
géré que michel le bouquet à côté samedi
et surtout je pense que jamais
l'appliquer le bouquet la loge de
mariage sur moi nos invités absolument
alors regardez dans mauvais esprit lam
lam de michel muller le malheureux va
dans le corps de ce bébé donc les
confédérés winter et thierry lhermitte a
cessé toute l'histoire du film et le
bébé traître avec il a la haine quand
ils arrivent ils à la haine
oui la loi ce que c'est ce film c'est ça
c'est la n 7 et c'est pour ça que ça
risque de plaire beaucoup parce que bon
on fait dans le mois c'est voici la
haine à la la belle-mère en l'occurrence
moi c'est un bon stress se lit sur mon
stress le bébé c'est l'heureux c'est pas
mal c'est vraiment c'est bien alors
l'âme de michel muller va dans le corps
du bébé dans le film et maintenant donc
on va faire comme si l'âme d'ophélie
winter était entré dans votre corps que
maria pacôme
imaginez un moment où je sois y est
habité comme ça je fais lilas vous êtes
ophélie interview dans la peau de
fellini
quand vous appelle ophélie ou afellay
afellay ophélie ophélie vous êtes
toujours très très très sexy c'est quoi
votre votre secret j'ai pas de secret je
suis né comme ça avec cette séduction
est extraordinaire c'est espèce de
féminité et ce talent à tout casser j'y
peux rien c'est comme ça c'est la vie
ophélie vous vous trouvez commandant
mauvais esprit superman faire quand même
parce que être odieuse comme ça et reste
c'est quand même belle élégante et faut
le faire j'ai fait ophélie aller comment
marié bat comme dans le film elle pas
mal et maria pacôme
elle a bien supporté la canicule non non
non
m
[Applaudissements]
ouais
un peu nuageux levitt maria pacôme
décidément j'aurais été un rosé par les
plus grandes
cet énorme arrêt et le théâtre felli
vous y pensez j'hésite
mais j'ai un peu peur mais ça va je
continue la chanson basque mais quand
même ce que je préfère et vos projets
dans les années qui viennent c'est quoi
vous achetez un jean taille basse
je ne sais pas vous essayez de vous
poser une question
pour le moment je vis au jour le jour je
pense que là je vais être très apprécié
dans ce que je viens de faire enfin j'ai
prouvé je suis une comédienne
jusqu'ici c'était petit et pas on avait
été assez dur avec moi je pense que là
on va voir que je suis ophélie est ce
que vous pouvez nous chanter un petit
bout de comment tout le monde le fait
mais non je connais pas que ce truc là
tout le monde le fait pas intéressé sur
la masturbation fait mal à la tête par
balle à la voilà
[Musique]
mais le bateau
mariage je vais vous libérez vous et
votre arbre si le principe tu pourrais
apporter la patrie mais je veux vraiment
l'emmener à huit a vu cet arrêt pour
beaucoup s'ils vont pas vouloir laisser
la maladie vous savez maria il ya un
truc exceptionnel au point info donc ça
fait quoi toi tu as des bois fleuri tu
sûr mais il a été acheté à vintimille
cher et d'escroquerie c'est vous savez
maria que les feuilles se fume un mari
vers sinon rien
[Musique]
et maintenant non mais m'ont laissé
mosquito
nos mémoires
non mais mon instinct mosquito retourne
chez toi alors moustique vous entendez
ce soir une expérience unique de
téléachat aulas unique 5000 librairies
sont restées ouvertes ce soir en france
oui et tous ces libraires sont derrière
leurs caisses et attendre mousty que
vous vendiez votre livre et ils
attendent les clients
on va voir ce qu'est un raz-de-marée
cergy est ce qu'on peut cadrer très
serré notre ami moustiques
merci voilà long sur lui oui très bien
et ce qui peut y aller
mussig vous avez deux minutes à partir
de maintenant mais pour nous vendre
votre livre c'est à vous je me doutais
que vous alliez me poser la question est
donc voici ce livre qui sortira en
librairie
le 10 novembre mais en l'occurrence ce
soir dans votre émission
c'est un livre qui se compose de
quelques pages plate ouais avec des mots
noire écrit sur fond blanc ouais et
décoller très fort ce qui fait que l'on
peut lire ce livre en sautant sur une
jambe
on dansant sur une poutre en lisant sur
un toit l'abri des courants d'air en
suçant abonnés il a beaucoup beaucoup
davantage il est comme vous pouvez le
voir rectangulaire est très beau avec
quatre coins way et commence par un
début qui est ici dont je le montre et
une fin qui est la 1 et donc c'est un
journal de moi j'ai fait un peu le tour
du monde dans une cave au pays basque
donc il ya quelques réflexions
personnelles
donc je peux vous en livrer quelques
unes des courte puisque je n'ai que deux
minutes donc lundi 28 avril
il ya une chose qui m'énerve dans la
position du prestige c'est qu'on me dise
que j'ai un joli dalmatiens alors que
c'est un labrador
il y en a un court c'est plus j'entend
brigitte bardot - j'aime mon chien
ouais ouais
[Musique]
non ouais
donc dire quand même à nos amis
téléspectateurs que c'est le tome 2003
oui ce qui suppose qu'il ya eu 2002 tous
bien sûr c'est publié chez flammarion
ouais voilà alors on n'est pas là ce
soir pour poser une carte de bons
clients mousty oui mais vous pouvez
revenir quand vous voulez à mélanger les
cartes de bons clients mais de douala
prenez votre carte de bonbons chanson
qui voilà pourquoi j'avais quand vous
voulez il n'y a pas de problème à
moustiques vous êtes le bienvenu ici
voilà c'est gratuit
tullow
si je la halle de moi
non mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
maintenant j'en normandie
bonsoir jean marc alors jean marc tout
le monde parle de votre émission
consacrée à la télévision sur europe 1
et à 38 ans vous effectué un come back
réussi comme journaliste et comme
rédacteur en chef
ça prouve est finalement que que l'on
peut sortir des plis de cases dans
lesquelles on vous mais d'une certaine
façon heureusement heureusement je
croyais que c'était impossible en france
je pensais qu'on était à vie dans ces
petites cases animateur de télé trash
etc je m'aperçois qu'on peut en sortir
c'est pas mal là il ya quand même une
vie après la télé ben oui la preuve
voilà alors votre émission c'est tous
les jours de 10h30 à 12h sur europe 1
vous êtes le leader des émissions de
radio consacrée à la télévision alors
pendant longtemps il faut dire les
choses les radios n'ont pas voulu parler
de la télévision le lendemain parce que
ça voulait dire que si on parlait il
s'était passé en est qu on ait quelqu'un
à l'écouté pas la radio bon et puis un
jour ils sont ni dans le fond façon
personnes écoutent la radio le soir
c'est clair pas grand monde dix ans donc
on va parler de la télé vous avez été le
premier sur rmc info
et ça a pris une importance considérable
puisqu'il ya vous il ya evelyne thomas
le sommaire d'un gosse qui sera là et
marco biagi elle aussi et c'est alors
donc c'est chez vous jean marc morandini
sur rmc que bernard montiel a fait sans
hara kiri médiatique en direct vous
l'aviez averti vous pendant la pub
pendant la pub je les fais attention tu
balances vraiment beaucoup et lui m'a
dit écoute façon c'est pas grave j'ai
pas d'amis dans ce métier dont se
passeraient avec personne à la maison
moi je trouve ça plutôt s'en aille c'est
très courageux et très bien à l'aise
bien alors montiel a été viré tf1 comme
vous mais pas pour les mêmes raisons
finalement vous donc l'émission à
l'époque c'était tout est possible
l'émission qui faisait 65% de parts de
marché du délire quand on y repense
aujourd'hui c'est incroyable ce trailer
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand il certaines
émissions font 45 % mais 65% de parts de
marché ça c'est évidemment voilà maxime
dans le titre et tout est possible et la
direction de tf1 voulu
vous continuiez à oui oui tout à fait à
la démission duré quatre ans au bout de
la troisième année moi j'ai voulu
arrêter parce que l'émission ne
correspondait plus vraiment moi j'ai dit
je veux arrêter et tf1 à ce moment là
m'a dit non il faut continuer c'est une
émission qui cartonne donc j'ai continué
une année de plus à la fin vraiment j'en
pouvais plus quoi cette haute mer alors
vous avez été viré en fait pas par tf1
mais par la presse oui on peut dire ça
comme ça c'est vrai qu'à une vraie
campagne de presse contre l'émission qui
trouvait les missions beaucoup trop
trash et c'est d'ailleurs assez drôle
quand on voit les programmes
d'aujourd'hui parce que quand on voit ce
qu'il fait aujourd'hui à la télé on se
rend compte que c'était cette émission
pour les enfants de choeur avait aucun
tout est possible argelès est vrai que
ça vachement comment est-ce que tu peux
réagir par rapport aux gens qui
t'appelle puisque toi tu y as la base de
cette télé trash
en fait je connais les mécaniques de ces
émissions est en fait le message que
j'essaie de faire passer aux gens sur
europe 1 c'est de leur dire ne vous
laissez pas avoir par ce type d'émission
voilà comment ça se passe derrière voilà
quels sont les coulisses de ce type
d'émissions indirectes libération avait
quand même titre et de morandi est un
con mais je trouve que c'est très
violent d'attaquer les gens dont ce
qu'ils sont dire ce mac rae est un con
juste parce qu'on l'a vu une heure et
demie par mois à la télé ça n'a pas de
sens mais pourquoi aujourd'hui la presse
dit pas fontaine et batailles sont des
cons ou tout ça pourquoi ça a changé ça
je sais pas je ne sais pas pourquoi ça a
changé mais je pense que c'est vrai
qu'on ya tellement des missions de ce
type là aujourd'hui que c'est un peu
noyés dans la masse enfin nous conte et
qui est interdit dans la presse
française bien non alors vous avez été
accusé jean marc morandini de voyeurisme
de racolage évidemment vous le sentiez
un petit peu quand vous faisiez
l'émission parce que bon vous êtes
conscient de ce que vous faites vous
avez tenté de déprogrammer un reportage
où une jeune femme s'était inoculé le
sida
par amour pour son compagnon qui était
atteint de la maladie c'est vrai que ça
fait partie des choses vraiment là je
trouvais que la limite était dépassé
mais problème c'est que dans cette
émission tout est possible moi je
n'avais pas la main sur l'émission
j'étais pas le producteur de l'émission
fait j'étais simplement le présentateur
et donc j'arrive et on me disait voilà
le sommaire c'est ça il ya tel sujet tel
sujet moi j'étais en plateau et je
présentais l'émission donc vraiment
quand ça allait trop loin comme dans ce
cas précis j'arrivais à mettre un holà
mais il fallait vraiment se battre il ya
un autre cas aussi vous avez interrompu
ses l'entretien avec un homme qui avait
vendu ses deux enfants pour cent mille
francs même vous
des scrupules sur la famille qui avait
acheté les enfants étaient très
mécontents quand j'ai reçu ce mec là je
pensais que je pensais qu'ils auraient
exprimé des remords il n'avait aucun
remords c'est un truc que je comprends
pas excusez moi mais c'est quand la
presse et savent bien qui décide des
sujets non
la presse ne s'est pas la presse ne sais
pas qui avait trahi cette émission la
presse vous accusez vous alors que la
vraie responsable c'est ascal breugnot
quel vrai nom mais pascale breugnot elle
a une image aujourd'hui d'une fille
formidable qui a fait psy show qui a
fait avancer la télé l'enfant de lier
des niveaux non mais c'est vrai pascale
breugnot aujourd'hui j'ai lentement
c'était moi l'image de l'émission donc
c'est vrai qu'il fallait pas tout me
mettre dessus mais c'est aussi normal
franchement je fasse partie des gens qui
est accusé un moment moi je m'en veux
pour certaines choses je m'en veux de ne
pas avoir dit non plus vraiment non plus
c'est vrai que moi en tant que
présentateur un moment j'aurais pu dire
non je deviens plus je ne présente plus
cette émission ça c'est une des erreurs
que j'ai faite c'est de me laisser
emporter les temps quand un crime d'une
mercedes
exactement c'est clair en même temps
j'avais 25 ans j'étais sur tf1 en
deuxième partie de soirée c'était la
première fois de ma vie que présenter
une émission on est un peu ébahi par
tout ça à l'époque
à l'époque jean marc était assez stressé
à l'époque donneuse ap pas il était
assez stressé vous avez perdu 13 tirs et
super stressée 13 kg gré c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque un petit peu comme comme notre
michèle laroque vous pensiez vous
non non c'est vrai j'avais envie de
partir parce que je pensais sincèrement
qu'en france avec l'image qui avait
véhiculé la presse plus personne dans
les médias ne me ferais confiance
je pensais que cette image vraiment
difficile que j'avais allait ruiner à
tout jamais ma carrière en france je me
suis dit je vais partir aux etats-unis
là bas on me connaît pas et je vais
faire à nouveau mais d'ici là il ya un
truc moi j'ai connu ça c'est à dire que
quand on a perdu son job à la télé même
si on s'en fout un peu parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya aussi un moment au bon ça
soulage un peu faut dire la vérité mais
on ne peut pas échapper aux chauffeurs
de taxi qui vous disent avait dit non
alors d'ailleurs je comprends pas
pourquoi ils vous ont bien et parce que
vous étiez pas mal filmé alors ce qu'ils
ont mis à la place là franchement c'est
pas mieux
et donc c'est terrible parce qu'en fait
il faudrait vraiment sexy ou s'ils
pensent plus basse pour nous les
chauffeurs de taxi qui 10 euros pour
vous vous aviez renoncer à l'époque à la
télévision à la célébrité et puis vous
êtes allé sur chérie fm sur nostalgie
vous a fait doubler l'audience s'était
il faut savoir quand même que jean marc
morandini tamek qui fait doubler
l'audience
tu vas voir demain ça va doubler
l'audience avec celui-là ça marche c'est
pas la peine que je mente manque que les
rues commerçantes pour marquer c'est
toujours
je crois savoir que ton cul ne rentre
pas dans l'écran
[Applaudissements]
qu'à ce moment tous avec toi roth
c'est sale c'est ça alors parallèlement
à l'époque vous avez été intéressé par
internet vous avez créé tout est net et
génération gay point fr est-ce que
c'était parce que c'est important de
défendre la cause gay ou pour vous faire
plein de pognon fortement parce que
c'était un vrai créneau porteur va se
casser à paris n'a pas été ménagé avec
ça n'a pas vraiment pas ça pas voir ça
en revanche comme ça a recommencé à
marcher effectivement c'est sur rmc donc
rmc info émission sur la télé bonne idée
on l'a dit et vous augmentez la sempap
il a doublé l'audience il a augmenté de
135 % à ta ta ta ta ta moi j'ai
travaillé rmc et sont des copains tous
là bas
135% c'était facile suffisait qu'ils et
deux t2 auditeurs de plus depuis des
mois les copains peux pas m'empêcher
temps je les aime
alors le problème effectivement si vous
êtes tombés sur des sur des patrons un
petit peu c'est normal pour des patrons
un petit peu âpres au gain ce qu'ils
voulaient aussi des coups de téléphone
des auditeurs nombreux et payant
exactement la normale
non jean marc morandini tout le monde
attend votre retour à la télévision en
parle de france 3 le vendredi soir une
deuxième partie de soirée quand notre
ami marc olivier fogiel sera enfin le
dimanche soir oui c'est un projet par
projet parmi d'autres produits par
dechavanne produit par dechavanne qui
celui-là abouti se seraient produits par
d'autres projets oui il ya deux projets
c'est vrai que depuis que je parle un
peu de moi à nouveau et que c'est vrai
que ça marche c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que depuis que ça marche bien ce matin
et pas mal de producteurs qui viennent
me voir qui me propose des émissions
mais c'est vrai que je veux pas refaire
les erreurs du passé
dire que moi j'ai une condition qui est
importante c'est de dire je veux être le
patron de mon émission et voilà j'ai
payé une fois pour voir donc ça suffit
j'ai appris aujourd'hui si je fais une
émission je vais être le patron mon
émission et surtout je veux rester libre
de pouvoir dire ce que je veux en radio
sur europe 1 parce que c'est vrai que
l'une des particularités de l'émission
c'est la liberté de ton et je veux
garder cette liberté de pouvoir
critiquer toutes les chaînes alors ça
vous plairait de revenir dans la grande
famille de la télévision jean marc
encore une fois voilà mes conditions ici
vraiment sont mes conditions oui vous
savez quand on fait partie de la grande
famille de la télévision ont été obligés
d'aller faire des courses de voitures
avec dechavanne le dimanche vous savez
ça tu vas être obligé de marcher sur les
genoux parce que tu n'as pas le droit
d'être plus grands
et ça nous dérange pas d'être obligé de
les faire du dragster et vincent perrot
[Applaudissements]
quand on fait partie de la grande
famille de la télévision faut faire la
course du rhum avec christine bravo vous
savez ça ce sera plus simple à mon avis
c'est en tous les cas vous pensez avoir
la télévision la même liberté que vous
avez aujourd'hui à la radio non je ne
sais pas en tout cas c'est la condition
pour y aller si j'ai pas cette liberté
j'y répondrai pas un accro de la télé et
je pense pas que la radio toute façon
soit quelque chose de mineur
aujourd'hui c'est vrai quand on fait de
la radio la première question qu'on vous
pose c mais vous revenez quand on avait
moi je suis très bien à radio qui fait
de la télé bien c'est bien autre membre
une stratégie bungie fait vous désirez
j'entends bien alors jean marc morandini
maintenant vous êtes revenu dans la
grande famille de la télévision vous
êtes en est heureux de vous avoir
on va savoir un petit peu plus qui vous
êtes on va vous faire un hard et viau
vous pensez à quoi alors en ce moment là
je pense vraiment sincèrement je suis en
train de me demander si j'ai eu raison
de venir dans cette émission je pense
que oui pour l'instant quand vous vous
regardez le matin la glace vous dites
quoi
j'aime pas me regarder le matin dans la
glace je déteste ça ils se détestent mon
image je déteste me regarder à la télé
je me tais je déteste me regarder sur un
écran c'est non non j'aime pas du tout
ça mais croit qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui font de la télé qui sont comme ça
quand vous étiez petit vous auriez aimé
ressembler à qui avoue pourquoi moi
parce que je regardais déjà la télé
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois je pleure très souvent alors là ça
moi c'est vraiment de vendre un film
devant un film bien foutu ou changeriez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique à part votre pub
[Applaudissements]
et
vous pouvez vous dire de plus négatif
sur vous je pense que j'ai pas de talent
voilà je pense que je suis un gros
bosseur mais je pense que j'ai aucun
talent je crois que c'est ce que voulait
dire vous n'avez pas de dons mais du
talent oui parce que quand on réussit
c'est quand même du talent vous feriez
quoi s'il ne vous restait que 24 heures
à vivre
l'amour pendant 24 heures un fils aîné
envie de faire l'amour pendant 24 ans
oui pourquoi pas autant essayer c'est
avec du viagra et plusieurs personnes
voilà qu'avez-vous fait jean marc
morandini que nous ne sachions pas
je sais pas tout ce qui est ma vie
privée vous ne la connaissez pas et je
pense que c'est mieux comme ça
une bonne oeuvre une bonne action oui
mais ça se dit pas ça en fait
moi j'aime pas les gens qui vont à la
télé pour raconter leurs bonnes oeuvres
moi j'en fais mais je les garde pour moi
une mauvaise action plein à acheter que
les chaussures agressivement
[Musique]
c'est sûrement pas
bon maintenant passer à tout le monde
s'en mêle
[Musique]
je vais vous lire un petit texte de jean
lesieur le rédacteur en chef de télé 7
jours
cher thierry dans votre dernière
émission le journaliste william reymond
a tenus sur moi des propos
incompréhensibles mais empreint de
méchants sous-entendus sur des raisons
je le site personnel
kim aurait incité à critiquer son
documentaire sur kennedy
tout cela parce que j'avais osé souligné
dans télé 7 jours que ces révélations
entre guillemets a lancé comme inédite
et sensationnel daté de cinq ans pour
les plus neuves de 19 ans pour les plus
anciennes
j'avais ajouté que l'on pouvait se les
procurer sur internet en quelques clics
j'aurais pu préciser que le nom de
william vraiment n'était nulle part
associés ayant dans une autre vie
journalistique abondamment étudier la
sphère kennedy je ne crois pas moi non
plus dit jean lesieur à la version
officielle attribuant aux seuls lee
oswald la responsabilité du meurtre de
kennedy
mais quand william reymond et canal+
prétendent nous révéler entre guillemets
enfin la vérité sur le complot alors
qu'ils ne font que recycler les vieilles
choses
il se moque du public sinon comment se
fait-il que leurs films sur une énigme
aussi fascinante n'est pas relancer
toutes sortes d' enquête en particulier
aux états unis
je ne vois pas en quoi des observations
aussi évidente pour m être inspiré par
de mystérieuses raisons entre guillemets
personnel autre que la plus élémentaire
des exigences de journalistes bien à
vous jean lesieur rédacteur en chef de
télé 7 jours bon moi j'ai traité cette
affaire on l'a traité en radio sur
europe et je pense qu'en fait l'erreur
vient peut-être de canal plus et c'est
ce que m'a dit bernard nicolas g a fait
le sujet justin williams an avec william
reymond l'erreur de canal+ et d'avoir
communiqué dans la presse en disant on
va vous révéler la vérité sur la sphère
kennedy et bernard nicolas lui même qui
a fait l'enquète me dit non c'est pas ça
on va vous donner une piste et je pense
qu'à dire on va vous révéler la vérité
forcément on est déçu lé tiff voilà
voilà jean marie j entends tous les
matins de 10h 30 à minuit
et maintenant
parent
[Musique]
si tu y as a king
ça va ça ouais il est bien c'est le
blouson qu'il faudra mettre avec aux
courses de voitures avaient recueilli
allen le dimanche ça sera très bien
alors tonia vous êtes avec bénédicte
delmas et adeline blondieau l'une des
trois héroïnes de la série sous le
soleil diffusé le samedi sur tf1 vous
êtes jessica là j'ai rendu du saint
tropez
en fait vous avez rejoint les deux
autres onzième épisode parce qu'avant
vous il y avait mallaury nataf
qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue mallaury
nataf agence à rien elle a eu un enfant
mais alors ici nous regardent à peine
mois et vient dans cette émission tu la
bienvenue même si personne n'en parle
moi quand vous voulez garder alors saint
tropez donc comme on dit à l'étranger et
sous le soleil en france gros succès
depuis 96
il ya d'abord en france bien sûr et
ensuite il ya 80 pays qui est assez
énorme
c'est un boulot de chien non non on est
moins j'adore mon travail est comme moi
vous avez fait 300 épisodes en six ans
dallas a fait la même chose mais en 15
ans donc c'est énorme
oui mais c'est parce que non non tu vois
pas non c'est c'est vraiment parce que
la production c'est un des seuls
production qui travaille à un doublé qui
parallèle
donne la possibilité de sortir 44
épisodes où les américains ils ont sorti
le 22 ouais et en plus c'est en maillot
de bain dans le froid vous en étonnez et
bien en été c'est vrai ils ont des
doudounes comme ça et on leur dit
allez-y moteur il enlève la doudoune il
rentre dans l'eau non c'est vrai
ouais mais là les choses qui marchent le
mieux c'est la bouillotte j'ai mis cinq
ans à les trouver mais le bouillotte
juste avant de tourner c'est parfait
c'était tu fais ça aussi dans le bas du
dos et si oui par esso
[Rires]
le problème le problème c'est un petit
peu comme bernard montiel problème tout
le monde si j'en avais un problème que
bernard montiel désormais c'est pas ça
si vous êtes non c'est un bon soldat tf1
fait consciencieusement la promotion de
la série partout où vous allez vous et
on vous donne rien d'autre lui il avait
vidéo gag il voulait faire 30 millions
d'amis on lui a jamais donné c'est vrai
et vous vous aimez beaucoup les animaux
aussi c'est vrai et on vous a jamais
donné d'autres émissions vous êtes trop
trop jolie trop blonde écoute
non mais il a raison de le dire il a
raison de le dire parce que j'ai j'ai
entendu que certaines échos comme ça et
je trouvais ça assez aberrant
on c'est vrai qu'il ya mon accent qui
est une bonne excuse aussi mais dans une
machine quand je les fais c'était pas
prévu pour l'américaine tourné avec
halloween il faut le dire oui c'est très
pathogène pardon comment ça s'est passé
il était gentil avec vous ouais bien
alors donc donc oui vous pensez qu'à la
direction de la chaîne ya des gens qui
vous reprochent votre physique votre
accent je pense que c'est un reproche je
pense que dans leurs idées ils nous
mettent dans une case 1 et ils ont du
mal à imaginer autre chose surtout après
sept ans en faisant le même personnage
et je pense aussi à un moment donné ils
savaient pas envie
il n'avait pas envie de nous donner une
possibilité de faire autre chose parce
qu'ils avaient peur de vous perdre dans
sous le soleil
c'est un peu cette je me bats à dire que
si on utilise des américains comme par
exemple on voit friends et ils sortent
et qu'on autre chose mais long métrage
mousty ça fait sept ans que ça existe
ouais
chirac ça fait plus longtemps encore oui
mais lui je sais alors vous avez un
accent formidable un petit peu comme
jean claude van damme est ce que vous
parlez le
ce que vous parlez le van damme est ce
que pareil van damme et a pu dans ta
life en ce moment oui je suis très
rapide
tu vas playes forever dans la série à
son soleil non j'ai pas envie de dire me
devenir ma musique c'est quoi tes gosses
aujourd'hui lé voilà on est onze
carrière dans la vie ouais non non dans
ta carrière tu as fait des miss tech
parce que tout le monde comprend que je
connais pas compris c'est que le van
damme c'est la langue de l'avenir parce
que évidemment tout le monde parle que
comme ça dans la mystique dans leur
carrière tonia les mains je pense pas
que j'en ai fait qu enfin j'ai suivi mon
instinct et ça m'a amené là où je suis
aujourd'hui je suis très contente le mot
steam par tom c'est le feeling est oui
oui je pourrais te faire un kiss après
l'émission création un chouette
voilà donc tonia cherche des rôles où
elle n'est pas victime de l'eau sur rail
hainaut georges chaîne sur le réel
souhait raceway belle vallée soir elle
va wild card vous avez un problème aux
états unis de façon si vous allez
chercher du boulot là-bas si vous avez
épousé un français ya quinze ans je
disais ça pour être un petit peu correct
maintenant si vous avez vécu dans des
conditions un peu bizarre c'est pas
c'est le service public ici konya
certain standing à respecter votre papa
ouais tu es obligé de se battre dans un
bar du michigan pour défendre son enfant
tonia parce qu'elle avait épousé un à
cause de la position française
je persiste à dire alors justement les
french fries sont devenus des freedom
fries certaines resteront
gens sont très sains vous vivez comment
cette brouille entre nos deux pays
je trouve c'est vraiment bête parce que
les choses le plus bête c'est à cause de
l'ignorance tout simplement en amérique
et donc une source d'information qui cnn
ou les les cinq chaînes qui sont
vraiment pro bush enfin pro ministre à
sion ashton qui en place actuellement et
ils n'ont pas à l'accès à l'info où il
contrôlait quoi moi ce qui est aberrant
je suis c'est que en étant américaine on
a l'impression que on peut même plus
parler donner notre avis parce que bush
il a fait une politique dont pire
américaine alors si on parle contre
aussi on est contre la guerre ou qu'on
dit quoi que ce soit on est considéré
comme non patriotes j'avoue être comme
un petit peu à l'époque du maccarthysme
poussée des black lui a dit moi votre
situation est impossible parce que vous
avez des états unis vous êtes considéré
comme ayant épousé un français en france
d'être considérés comme jouant dans sous
le soleil
pierre de chalets votre avis quel est
votre avenir franchement c'est sûr mais
bien bah écoutez tenir entre nos deux
pays
on va vous demander de choisir on va
faire une interview fromage ou dessert
[Musique]
oui oui oui oui oui vous êtes mieux
comme ça ah merci bien
je pensais qu'elle aimait vendredi est
ce que vous êtes plutôt chirac ou plutôt
bush
est ce que vous êtes plutôt jerry lewis
ou michel leeb attention
attention faut bien répondre sur le coup
parce que il ya un conte connaît très
très bien ils sont un peu moins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes plutôt navarro ou
colombo colombo vous êtes plutôt paris
texas où paris france vous êtes plutôt
star wars ou star ac
vous êtes plutôt indiana jones ou
patrick simpson john tu crois que ça
fait que c'est peut-être qu'elle sinon
non bingo le plus tôt elvis presley ou
dick rivers
vous êtes plutôt michael jackson ou marc
dutroux
non quand même ah oui j'aurais peut-être
d'ici ou alors j'aurais fait ça
m'envoyer regarder web ou 10 mars enfin
je crois
est ce que vous connaissez une émission
adam au fil des tours la donne un nom
c'est la première fois depuis 1965
baradat et puis à votre copain
maintiennent aussi passé à regarder non
thierry ardisson cela ni d'ailleurs il a
du coeur
thierry ardisson tout cela n'est
d'ailleurs il a du coeur
thierry ardisson solennité heures il a
du coeur ils arrêtent et dire la vérité
enfin même s'il a démenti l envie de
revenir bien alors dernière question
tonia très très sérieusement est-ce que
vous êtes plutôt baseball ou baissent
tout court
alors qu'au baseball ou baise tout court
est là quoi j'ai bien entendu
lasa et maintenant voir les greniers
les ministres wallons les magiciens qui
n'y arrive pas si si
[Musique]
ouais
et oui voici steevy et si je vous ai
accueillis steevy avec parler quand même
musique voir
oui c'est que sort actuellement un dvd
de la pièce de laurent ruquier qui
s'appelle la presse est unanime
mise en scène par agnès boury avec
claude sarraute isabelle alonso isabelle
mergault jérémy l'est raphaël misrahi et
vous steevy
[Musique]
marié deux combattants pour ce sont
celles-là attend 24 tonnes elle est
magnifique
non mais elle arrache tout cette
province j'adore peut-être un petit peu
je chanterai derrière quand même ma came
aux ya des côtés comme ça depuis
mireille darc haut mais de qui tu me
parles là ça date du muet il veut qu'on
pense que j'ai des sciences car ap ça
sera la fois très bien et pour le film
de stéphanie et pour vos antiquité
grecque
alors pour l'instant d'antiquités
grecques gens voient qu'une devant moi
j'suis pas sûr que je vais ouvrir le
chapitre tout de suite non mais attendez
là mais c'est pour gala quand même
elle se fout de ma gueule l'antiquité
grecque où elles veulent vraiment me
faire poser pour sa revue coiffeuse mais
qu'est ce qui se passe ici
pourrais tu dire cela mais vos merdes
quoi on affirme qui sort demain des jt à
faire plein d'interviews tournée devant
nous ça serait bien qu'on avance un peu
là
vous n'êtes pas là en train de le faire
croire que vous avez couché avec ma
femme avec votre femme que l'idée
saugrenue non avec elle la routine quoi
est ce que la star est prête on est en
retard mais voilà qu'arrive un grand rex
tout est un chien
[Musique]
mais je sais ça
tu as
comedia je crois que ce sampler n'est
pas du tout usurpée tout mandat vue
civique vous étiez un comédien hors pair
je crois me choque j'ai beaucoup aimé
vraiment sais c'est que les tirs de
coups et j'ai quand même eu sur scène un
tassement lombaire des postes dans deux
vertèbres contre le mur aussi parce que
moi sur 5 g feront qu'au coach n'a peur
de rien donc je je jette à trestel sont
bien cracher sur le jour une fois ça
arrive et la tête en première et voilà
ta selon berne le tout mais bon c'est
tellement un moment de bonheur qu'on
envoie ses pales tension convient a
découvert les joies de la comédie
l'actorat je dirais même au delà de
l'économie et de puis voilà quoi vous
êtes invités par votre nouveau métier
voilà voilà vous avez d'autres
propositions depuis cet encours était à
des théâtres de pièces normalement mais
c'est que des projets dont
[Applaudissements]
le seul regret
ce que je voulais dire à nos amis que
spectateur sait que la presse est
unanime mais n'est pas à la fiche pour
le moment et qui peuvent aller voir donc
on tire bien sûr les lapins au théâtre
fontaine de gerpinnes teurs ses
excellents je vous conseille d'y aller
parce que là vous allez vraiment vous
imprégnez vous de cet acte aura qui
désormais constitue le coeur de votre
vie steevy rythme vous rendez votre
casque est là parce que j'ai peur d'un
truc
ah ouais j'ai tapé faisait pas non
sérieux en changeant de couleur de
cheveux vous avez pas peur d'eux a pris
un gros risque pour votre carrière
non nous avons france j'espère pas que
dams car je sais pas je sais pas je sais
pas non moi j'aime bien comme ça à
écouter les gens vont s'y faire c'est
très bien vous trouvez ça bien tonia oui
oui bon ça me fait drôle d'être à côté
d'elle parce que ça fait tellement
d'années que vous à regarder à la
télévision en fait c'était un grand fan
de sous le soleil et de la vanille et
bien non mais sérieusement pourquoi vous
avez abandonné le jaune pour vos cheveux
platine jeu nous sommes là c'est qu'est
ce qui s'est passé ça s'est passé comme
c'était c'était un mardi ou quoi non
c'était fin mardi font que peut-être je
me rappelle pas non mais déjà pour mes
cheveux c'est pas bon on ne peut pas
faire des colorations sur déclaration
tout le temps j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver chauve et à faire des implants
et les sourcils c'est pas naturel ceci
si mais tout est naturel sur sera
possible les sourcils comme ça jamais vu
ça moi bah ils sont extrêmement bien
dessinée vous savez bien il faut sortir
en dehors du bar ombre
tu veux dire je ferme les yeux je mets
cette musique je ferme les yeux je suis
au barreau excusez moi
[Musique]
non vous avez changé de couleur de
cheveux pourquoi vous en aviez marre des
débats c'est pas des blagues sur les
blondes
non parce que comme on reconnaît une
vraie blonde c'est une brune décolorés
concède un bon alors pourquoi est ce que
les blondes ont un boulot ici pourquoi
parce qu'il existe aussi des blonds
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour faire oublier le stv du loft
c'est bon ça pas du tout
non mais dites moi moi ah non mais on va
pas parler de ma cause des mutins le
retrouve toujours avec des bus elle est
revenue pour ça doit changer sa couleur
de cheveux
bougez pas j'arrête vous êtes prêt à
quoi pour faire oublier le lot à rien
parce que je suis très fier d'avoir fait
le loft et son lofteuse en serait pas là
aujourd'hui
ouais donc voilà je suis très
reconnaissant envers vous êtes prêt à
renoncer aux fautes de français par
exemple concret avec le temps fait des
progrès alors maintenant en plus dans la
tout essayé ou fait des disques enfin
non je enfin je fais des disques pour
enfants
oui ça s'appelle les comptines 2stv 23
petites comptines sur les animaux et la
nature présenté l'une après l'autre avec
beaucoup de tendresse ce qu'écrit et
d'humour par stevie un album très joyeux
à la fois drôle et émouvant
c'est chez sony music voilà alors ce
qu'il faut dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est qu'avant chaque
petite comptine ya une petite racontines
et la petite raconte insee steevy qui
présente la petite comptine
c'est magnifique vous ne m'en voudrez
pas steve j'ai choisi la carotte mais il
n'ya pas que les lapins qui mangent des
carottes
le petit cochon lui aussi en raffolent
le jour des épluchures de carotte c'est
si bon qu'il en centre et le rock
alors inutile de lui dire ajouté
dans le piège de la bière ce disque de
stevie est autobiographique mais la
musique ou les lapins qui mangent des
carottes
le petit cochon lui aussi en raffolent
mime le jour des épluchures de carotte
c'est si bon qu'une enchanterait le rock
[Applaudissements]
non mais je peux maintenant je pensais
que j'avais fait ça pour faire un peu de
pognon et tout et j'ai compris en
l'écoutant que c'était parfaitement
autobiographique c'est de vous dans ne
paraît pas telles pratiques aux gens qui
mangent des carottes
ça c'est vous après si j'ai fait ce
produit c'est que je suis très attaché à
cette tradition qui se perd
malheureusement les parents raconter des
histoires à leurs enfants avant de
s'endormir pour les maisons mais c'est
vrai mais non et quel est le véritable
atout c'est que en plus ça permet aux
enfants de enfin ça développe leur côté
créatif parce que les imaginer
c'est vous qui avez des idées mal
placées donc voilà donc ça c'est la
racontines qui vient avant la cantine et
puis après évidemment après il ya la
comptine 2stv
je préfère c'est le jour des carottes
oui le jour des épluchures de carottes
[Musique]
mais il n'ya pas que les lapins qui
mangent des carottes
le petit cochon lui aussi en raffolent
stevie fait c'est l'attaquant les
vieilles dans la rue bah oui c'est sûr
donc ça s'appelle les comptines 2stv par
stevie voilà alors à maintenant tester
un petit peu comme chez laurent ruquier
d'ailleurs à maintenant tester vos
qualités de comédien steevy à hay et
concentrez-vous et on va faire une
interview mensonge
[Musique]
mais plein cible est simple steevy doit
répondre en mentant à iéna pour qui ce
serait pas difficile ici bien sûr un
mais pour vous c'est un petit peu
compliqué vous êtes tellement pur mon
petit cochon stevie ça se passe comment
avec ruquier très très mal est fait
souffrir
donc ça veut dire que ça va très bien na
la députée a choisi pourquoi alors
inquiet pour mon corps à 6 lors qui tu
aimes son humour ou alors là pas dit
cela je crois que c'est pas un bon et
dis-moi steevy tu crois que tu auras un
molière un jour oui je pense ouais tu
sais qui c'est molière bien sûr pas du
tout
[Applaudissements]
si tu sais qu'il ya beaucoup de rumeurs
ont couru sur toi non à 6-6 oui non mais
si un jour ton fils tu annoncé qu'il est
hétérosexuel tu réagirais comment
[Rires]
j'aurais pas de fils stevie tu m'aimes
pas du tout
st
je suis
ah non alors mr frc le jour et carottes
où il joue les épluchures
alors là
[Musique]
et maintenant
mais pas moi
mais si gaby cohn bendit
[Musique]
gamigo minutes bonsoir monsieur frère de
dany donc et lui mon frère j'ai dix ans
de plus d'accord jusqu'à 68 jamais un
frère depuis je suis devenu le sien
voilà donc dany cohn bendit et voltaire
vous êtes enseignant surtout connu pour
avoir été le cofondateur du lycée
expérimental de saint nazaire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans ce lycée
parce que tout le monde parle de ce
lycée est ce que c'est l'endroit où les
profs épousé des élèves et inversement
il y a eu ça aussi ils vivent depuis
plus de 15 ans ensemble
oui il ya des profs vous savez il ya eu
ça aussi oui il ya eu quoi d'autre et on
apprend à devenir des citoyens et pas
ceux qu'on fabrique dans nos lycées les
autres des moutons des casseurs mais
nous sommes par intéressant donc voilà
vous êtes un ex enseignant dans 7 à la
retraite très active dans le milieu
associatif et vous publier une lettre
ouverte à tous ceux qui n'aiment pas
l'école
lancez votre contribution au débat sur
l'éducation nationale défense des
pédagogues novateur dont on aurait fait
partie ce que claude allègre appelle les
pédagogos vous êtes un guide à gogo
voilà et est mon ami finkielkraut les
gardes rouges de la culture voilà voilà
et ça donc c'est pour répondre à ces
gens là qui vous regarde assez
facilement alors le titre de votre
bouquin lettre ouverte à tous ceux qui
n'aiment pas l'école prend évidemment le
contrepied de celui de luc ferry d'être
ouverte à ceux qui aiment l'école alors
quand vous parlez de deux ferries vous
dit c'est pas parce qu'on est prof de
philo qu'on est philosophe 1 et j'ai pas
du tout pensé à fait rimer un peu aussi
penser à tirer
ce n'était pas voulu ceci dit je reviens
la voir ah bah ouais j'aurais regardé
j'aurais écouté quoi c'est ce qui dit
d'ailleurs il dit qu' il dit en parlant
de l'autorité si le travail en classe
était intéressant l'autorité irait de
soi bien sûr oui c'est vachement bien
saignant respectait les élèves les
élèves les respecter voilà alors quand
on dit ah ah ah gaby cohn bendit
il ya trop de mai 68 dans l'éducation
actuelle lui dit pas du tout ça c'est
complètement rigidifier après 68 et en
fait il n'a pas assez
si ça va mal dans nos lycées c'est que
mai 68 n'a laissé aucune trace dans la
tête des enseignantes dans le système
éducatif de ce que dit luc ferry c'est
intéressant alors vous vous êtes par
exemple contre le le salaire au mérite
ce que vous dites c'est que quand on
quand on institue les primes
ce ne sont pas les meilleurs qui gagnent
les prix mais ce sont les chasseurs de
primes ce sont les failles et sache les
remarques et surtout en afrique où moi
j'étais sans primes d'expatriation au
burkina faso j'ai remarqué que les
enseignants qui partent et les
fonctionnaires qui partent en afrique
avec mes primes d'expatriation c'est
vraiment pas pour aider les pays les
pays là bas c'est vraiment pour la prime
d'expatriation pas mal de temps
lorsqu'il faut dire quand même pas tout
à fait honnête c'est que vous avez
terminé votre carrière
quinze mille balles par mois etc à la
retraite aujourd'hui vous avez 13000
c'est pas énorme c'est vrai moi je pense
que c'est bien tout ce qui est au dessus
et scandaleux excusez moi thierry
ardisson et tout ce qui est en dessous
et scandales et où moi je trouve c'est
bien en plus on est deux
ça fait 26 mille fonds de retraite en
sélection comptant en france je trouve
que c'est très bien ainsi je maintiens
que ça va ça va bien on vit bien et on
peut aider un enfant qui comme tout le
monde et vous n'avez jamais fait grève
pour avoir une augmentation de salaire
ça depuis plus de
oui 20 ou 30 ans alors justement quand
on parle de l'école en ce moment on
parle du port du voile c'est un dieu
normal vous avez signé avec dany cohn
bendit votre frère un point de vue dans
le monde où vous défendiez les deux
petites voiles et d'aubervilliers qu'on
nous a tellement reproché d'avoir su ici
j'étais à cet après midi avec laurent
lévy le père le père j'ai alors que ça
se passe pour l mal
ouais mal on va pas les recevoir et j'ai
plein d'amis chef d'établissement qui me
dit je les prendrais bien mais en
quelques extrémistes de gauche voire
d'extrême gauche sont battions 68 pour
le droit à l'expression politique dans
les établissements aujourd'hui
ouais veulent chasser les gamines parce
qu'elles ont le voit donc vous pensez qu
elles vont pas retrouver de lisser ces
petites voiles et d'aubervilliers
je crois pas j'ai plein d'amis qui
disent on les prendrait bien nous comme
chef d'établissement mais c'est
tellement dur va nous mener la vie
impossible lorsque vous dites mon cher
c'est d'accord avec ça finalement parce
que l'autre jambe on n'a pas trop parlé
mais je pense que finalement l'enfant un
petit peu comme vous l'enfant à l'école
pour rompre avec sa famille sa fille la
fille à un voile peut être après
plusieurs années d'école elle aura plus
envie d'emporter ce que disait bernard
henri lévy en 89 d'ailleurs même s'il a
changé d'avis depuis mais c'est chaud on
rentre avec des sabots et on ressort
avec les souliers vernis c'était un
petit peu sésame et au fc que le petit
avec pippa est la petite avec voile
après cette fait des déclarations
d'amour
ouais voilà avec des cols sort et
américains voilà avec n'importe quoi
tout ce qu'ils veulent et jette le voile
bien sûr que je suis passé des gamines
on le voit l'expérience là dessus que tu
as et bien vous dites c'est à l'école
d'être laïc pas aux enfants tout est
fait donc pas te crois pas de trucs à
l'école des gosses ils viennent comme
ils sont comme une famille en or ils
n'ont pas fait revoir leur point de vue
politique ou la religion dans une salle
aux couleurs prof marxiste machin mais
fasciné t il vendre leur camelote en
douce un cohn-bendit c'est pire qu'un
voie et que j'ai sur la tête
j'assume mon frère chaque fois que
j'avais des élèves les parents les
mettais en garde attention qu'à
cohn-bendit et ben oui se protéger et
alors
et ce ministre ferry qui envoie ces
petites poupées comme il les appelle à
l'école confessionnel catholique
voudrait interdire le voile à l'école
publique alors que l'école catholique
nous montre un exemple de tolérance
accepte les gamines avec voile et quand
on voudra interdire le voile est ce
qu'on en tire a qu'à l'école publique où
est-ce qu'on interdira aussi à l'école
confessionnelle qui acceptent les
gamines avec voile moi je trouve ça
monstrueux moi je préfère qu'elle soit
la laïque plutôt qu'au real
confectionneurs la voilà il ya deux
théories dans l'expression n'en parle
souvent ici il ya d'un côté pas de
liberté pour les ennemis de la liberté 1
cc robespierre et bien d'un autre côté
ce que moi j'essaie de défendre ici
c'est je ne partage pas vos idées mais
je suis prêt à mourir pour vous puissiez
les exprimer
phrase attribuée à condorcet ou à
voltaire aval au mr on s'en fou voilà
vous vous êtes plutôt pour la deuxième
solution mais cette espèce de refus de
l'intolérance
oui vous a amené à défendre à une
certaine époque des thèses par souci de
2,2 libertarisme oui mais à soutenir des
thèses qui était quand même pas facile
de défendre jeudi pour inviter les
spectateurs
vous n'êtes pas révisionniste évidemment
mais vous avez pensé un moment que les
thèses révisionnistes d'euphorie
s'empare exemple devaient pouvoir
s'exprimer mais ne serait ce que pour
pouvoir être réfutée j'ai pris je
comprends bien si c'était sont pas
exprimés on pouvait les réfuter et les
gens s'imaginent qu'il ya un an quand on
leur casser là dessus je voudrais
discuter avec vous je suis contre la
censure comme je suis contre la peine de
mort contre eux la peine de mort pour
tout le monde
son enfant mais les 1 500 enfants
deviennent on est contre la peine de
mort ou on est pour la peine de mort
pour les assassins d'enfants et paraît
donc je suis con y compris pour iceman
donc je suis contre la censure sur le
même principe contre toute censure
quelles que soient les idées
négationnistes compris je suis heureux
que ces derniers temps je savais bien
vous me poserez la question kerry c'est
normal tout à fait je viens de lire la
la la le petit bouquin de raul ou van
heghe m1 un des idéologues de 68
situationniste que j'adore et je
conseille à tous les jeunes de lire le
traité du savoir vivre à l'usagé des
jeunes générations c'est un livre
merveilleux merveilleux alors que diddy
de bord est un peu emmerdant je dois
avouer de raul van est gay mais merville
vient de sortir un petit livre rien
n'est sacré tout peut se dire préfacé
par robert ménard qui se bat à
tous se bat pour la liberté d'expression
oui les idées révisionniste doivent
pouvoir s'exprimer et on les combat et
on les combat on peut l'aimer valises et
intensivement on les interdit pas et en
gros j'avais dit à l'époque on ne compte
doivent ou ne combat bien que ses filles
s'expriment librement
35 ans après 68 ya toujours des cohn
bendit qui foutent la merde tu vois pas
bien
la seule question que je me pose par
rapport à ça c'est carrément bon vous
dites il faut qu'on puisse effectivement
donné des thèses révisionnistes ne
serait ce que pour les combattre on est
d'accord mais à un moment vous donnez
l'impression d'y avoir cru à un moment
c'est un moment vous êtes rentré dans
cette logique il ya est ce que vous le
savez il ya un article dans le canard de
nantes en mars 80 je dis pas que vous
êtes révisionnisme et je dis que vous
finissez par rentrer dans leur dans leur
logique à vous poser des questions sur
les gazages est lancée sur true jusqu'au
bout et c'est vrai que comme j'ai publié
ce texte dans libé 1 le droit de parole
ouais c'est après une discussion avec
lux man juste changé on va pas rentrer
dans le pas de liberté pour les ennemis
de la liberté mais à propos d'autres
trucs qu'on voulait interdire le front
national les meetings de le pen on était
contre l'interdiction
arrive la sphère faurisson j'ai dit on
fait ce texte pas de liberté pour les
ennemis de la liberté
il n'a pas voulu andré donc j'ai fait
tout seul après on matane et la vie en
me disant maintenant d'accord qu'un
ultra démocrates mais sur le fond tu dis
attendez je suis pas historien
j'aurais dû maintenir ce run j'ai
commencé à lire et j'ai été effrayée
effectivement à liszt à l'époque de
l'historiographie de cette question
c'était nul et les révisionnistes
s'amuser comme des petits fous à mettre
en contradiction et c'est vrai que ma
petite tête à ce moment là bas pas
historien c'est vrai que j'ai eu des
doutes mais jamais sûr ni la volonté
d'extermination
les historiens comme faurisson leur
mentalité me paraissait à combattre
politiquement et j'ai pensé que
peut-être que les chambres à gaz
n'étaient pas l'unique outil ou les
petits essentiel de l'extermination défi
est donc bon je suis revenu sur le
dernier point un genre c'est vrai bon
j'ai alors et alors et ma tête je veux
avoir le droit y compris de douté à un
moment si je doute c'est comme ça ne
peut pas être mis à l'index comme
lorsque je veux dire sérieux oui aller
loin oui mais toujours est ce qu'on
pourrait dire loin conclure gabriel cohn
bendit que vous êtes victime du litre à
démocratisme moi je suis pas victime
j'assume mon ultra démocratisme et je
dis que c'est comme ça qu'on avancera
d'accord
un gardien comme d'habitude est rouvert
à tous ceux qui n'aiment pas l'école
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant la preuve
m
[Musique]
haché
tu as is ou la tristesse
[Musique]
ce soir là mes enfants c'est une star de
land art grande que nous recevons ce
soir très heureux de vous voir dans très
heureux de vous voir vivante
vous n'êtes pas passé loin voilà c'est
la triste euse donc c'est vrai que la
mode était un petit peu entre 11 et
jerry le land art grand prix de l'inde
avance donné soixante et soixante dix on
a eu d'amis ici rue marie france on a eu
jenny bel'air on a eu une grippe
cavenne jean jacques schuhl enfin c'est
vrai qu'il ya un revival comme ça deux
de ces années 60 70 sont polis on peut
dire votre âge non non oui 60 dans 1
mois
voilà vous sortez un livre donc joujou
vous racontez votre histoire s'appelle
jusqu'à l'aube
en collaboration avec olivier miclo de
ces chez flammarion voilà une compil qui
s'appelle intégral comme
[Musique]
alors ça c'est tout art dont il ya tous
vos succès de l'époque et ça c'est un un
nouveau morceau vous avez fait avec
edward la salle auditionne à cesser la
voilà
il ya le livre il ya la compil il ya le
centre pompidou faut dire quand même les
choses dans le monde va dire des trucs
géniaux ce côté là plus personne n'a
entendu parler dans 20 ans et d'un seul
coup tu as un bouquin une compile une
rétrospective à beaubourg une
rétrospective ça c'est pas les noms
senna tous vos films du 23 janvier au 9
février tous vos films abobo est un seul
coup ça tombe sur vous comme ça mais que
c'est très violent quand même non tomtom
décès alors on va en revenir au livre
est d'abord évidemment quand on a un
livre comme le vôtre une chose qu'on
fait c'est qu'on regarde les photos
évidemment donc on va d'abord regarder
les photos après on parlera du texte
marié do
[Musique]
ap
zouk zouk quelques photographies tirées
du livre qui s'appelle jusqu'à l'aube et
qui paraît chez flammarion voilà alors
votre vrai nom c'est daniel cyr les uns
vous êtes né à blida en algérie
absolument alors vos parents s'étaient
rencontrés dans un dancing qui
s'appelait le paradis de la guerre voilà
votre mère était danseuse génial et puis
voilà lui rentre en métropole et puis
vous et moi qu'ils oublient un peu qu'il
a une femme et une petite fille
et puis way et quand vous arrivez vous
avez rendez vous sur un quai de gare à
marseille et il est pas là et il est pas
là et vous dites dans votre bouquin que
votre mère est passé directement du
paradis à l'enfer à l'enfer et voilà
j'adore ces histoires une chanson
populaire tisser voilà alors quand vous
étiez petit métier
déjà star 1 quand même vous regarder
dans le miroir tous à scotcher tous les
miroirs pour pas que vous voyez pas que
je me regarde et vous étiez une
excellente élève excellente a commencé à
passer son bac à 13 ans et demi ça
laisse rêveur et non c'est vrai et
malheureusement voilà vous commencez un
petit peu a traîné ouzou avec les
blousons noirs de la bastille le matin
vous quittez la maison habillée
normalement
et puis dans votre sac eux il ya un cuir
voilà voilà un jean débrouille toi tu es
ce qu'il faut voilà qu'elle se change il
ya un épisode c'est assez dur dans votre
vie quand pas s'étendre là dessus mais
qui n'en être explique beaucoup de
choses pour la suite c'est le vous allez
en vacances à un jour les pins vous fait
violer et l'ours qui est extraordinaire
c'est que cette maison où a lieu le le
viole la tue maison près de grasse a été
retrouvée par jean philippe smet qui
n'était pas encore ou qui commence à
être gênés à l'idée absolument écart
losc avait encore un an à l'époque chez
eux que je me suis dit que moi non plus
c'est le site et vos copains jour là m
mais moi je dis ah j'allais à jour les
pins chez mon cousin qui était il y
avait deux ans de plus que moi il y
avait cet endroit où johnny passait tous
les soirs et donc évidemment c'est mon
grand frère je colombien oui et donc
johnny et carlos vous aide à retrouver
la maison vous avez absolument c'est à
dire que bon mon cousin à me tourner
monte une expédition punitive quoi avec
johnny qui tout de suite il va
carlos qui étaient là aussi et puis
bonne dizaine d'autres personnes pour
retrouver ces mecs qui m'ont vraiment
laissé d'heure dans un fossé à moitié
mort et
voilà quoi voilà et c'est jean paul
goude l'excellent jean paul goude le
créateur de déflation
c'est ça qui est un mec génial un grand
artiste sur scène qui vous a réconcilié
avec la gente masculine avec l'amour
avec beaucoup de précaution ah oui alors
vous avez été mannequin pour lui mais
aussi pour des grandes marques vous avez
oui bah j'ai assez chiches et j'allais
même être mannequin vedette de saint
laurent pour sa toute première maison de
couture et malheureusement j'avais
beaucoup de mal à faire les trois huit
parce que je pensais tout maintenant
voilà après à 8h valait que je me pointe
parce qu'il y avait une pointeuse en
plus et en blouse up aussi le machin
truc m'a qui détestait maquille et tout
j'avais lieu maquillage de la veille le
peu qui reste c'est mascaret pas
beaucoup et j'allais dormir chez saint
laurent alors lui ça ne gênait pas
vraiment liseuse ou de temps en temps
laissez-les à dormir alors et pierre
bergé ça l'a un peu ennuyeux témoigne
marie faye est quand même encore
maintenant
ouais faut dire la vérité c'est que vous
passiez vos nuits c'est vrai ou pas
c'est vrai mais chez régine d'ailleurs à
tanger régine et c'est comme ça que vous
avez fini par tromper
jean-paul avec son meilleur ami j'ai
honte
ramdani mois alors voilà là vous devenez
zouzou la twist euse parce que à cause
de sa voix là parce que j'ai
[Musique]
chez régine y avait ça et vous commencez
à danser voilà d'un seul coup moi moi je
m'en souviens j'étais tout petit mais
quand même le twist explose ah oui et
puis il y avait surtout une bande la
bande des mecs de west side story qui
était allé à paris et qui avait amené
cette danse près je dirais donc on était
relaiera oui non il y avait la bande de
gaza history il y avait la bande de
vadim
il y avait le temps d'aider photographe
de paris match lequel paris match a
écrit si toulouse lautrec l'avait connu
il l'aurait pinte sous le nom de zhu zhu
la twist et cenon la goulue 61 voilà
alors évidemment alors il ya un truc que
je veux savoir quand même alors vous
aimerez pour me mettre 12 ya un moment
vous dites que vous allez dans un
endroit la ville tenue par jean marie
rivière et qu'edith piaf est là et qu
edith piaf et tourner un peu en
bourrique les gens et à un moment elle
fait tourner en bourrique le petit fils
d'un grand dites-vous présent la
république c'est qui le petit-fils du
général ça veut dire que le petit fils
du général de gaulle oui il était dans
cette boîte animée par jean marie
vianney piaf un jour l'obligent à se
déguiser en femme
oui et ensuite à faire un strip-tease et
non et non donc voilà non voilà ce qui
se passe là vite on a vu ce qui se
passait chez régine avec le twist où
j'allais évidemment chez castel et la
vie d'avant vous devenez ami c'est
extraordinaire la vie de deux ou veut
devenir ami avec george harrison et avec
sa femme et pattie boyd un et alors
c'est très rigolo vous raconter ça
sérieux quand elles partent en vacances
ha parce qu'un jour harrison dit moi je
vais faire ma tournée avec les beatles
et il s'en va il vous laisse vous avec
paty bol vous partez à saint tropez et
il vous fait des pétards traitez vous
roule pour trois semaines de pétards
watts de tampax plein iweb de tampax
plaît voilà voilà
et quand vous arrivez à saint tropez en
faisant les pétards ou les parts de
hutchison
quand même énorme et bien faire
mais pour que ça soit hier soir ce soir
sur le port de saint-tropez et vous en
offrir des crs voilà on est sur le port
et on nous demande nos papiers
d'identité d'abord mal tu es avec paty
et sa soeur qui comprennent rien et pas
qu'ils aient donné tout avec notre joint
quoi et donc il y en a un qui me dit
mais qu'est ce que vous fumez la
conduisit le tabac turcs je ne sais pas
a lancé vous êtes un tir à la cigarette
dur et j'ai dit vous en voulez mais qui
me dit oui jeudi à la trappe le paquet
je suis en offre une hockey et puis avec
pas qui on se dit oh tu fais signe qu'il
vaut mieux prendre la tangente
on se tire et on repasse une heure après
pour voir il serait de f1 et on voi le
mec à 6 devant chez sénéquier avec son
pote mais dont les deux des yeux ou non
on s'est dit c'est génial
d'ailleurs le lendemain le lendemain le
lendemain qu'elle est quelqu'un qui dise
zidoria les crs qui tient chaud partout
et en fait il voulait du tabac tuera
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors la vie joojoo qu'équipe
d'eau dans ce bouquin c'est absolument
extraordinaire je le conseille
après vous rencontré brian jones le le
rolling stone le plus extraordinaire
leblanc avec les douze jusque là le
mythique destot le fondateur du groupe
le pot et vous vous installez voilà chez
lui à chelsea
donc là vous trompez un petit peu michel
mahler que ça recommence
mais c'est une possibilité a trompé vous
avez quand même excusez moi c'est pas
les cigarettiers
oui j'avais pourtant j'étais une grande
idéaliste je rêvais de grand amour pour
la vie et la d embûches tout le temps
sur mon chemin sinon la vie on fout
d'être là c'est pas de votre faute en
fait ailier fort et aux armes à feu dire
la vérité je vais vous dire honnêtement
je connais pas michel ménard oui mais
pour moi c'est ça effectivement après
mais au début j'ai pas une seconde c'est
peut-être vous le voyez c'est au
bilboquet bilboquet il veut monter leur
saint-benoît et que vous échangez vos
potes et après une trêve à gaza faire
qu'il y avait un truc en plastique blanc
le bleu klein roll vous l'appelez là
mais le titre louis et toits de chaume
voilà alors vous trompez michel bon
alors les fans des fennecs n'ont marqué
les fans d'histoire vu des tests celle
ci devant la maison il ya des filles qui
bat la journée l'agent [ __ ] de
française [ __ ] de francona a indiqué
brian may et voilà et vous fait vos
débuts dans la chanson we fait vos
débuts dans la chanson à ce moment là
grâce à pierre bénichou alors bon là il
ya la rupture avec brian jones et un
jour il vous met un morceau en écoutant
les paroles vous dites il veut plus de
moi c'est génial
est il de la state la veine film et vous
découvrez à ce moment là que vous êtes
accroché au speed way et après ça
commence alors la bon grave quoi
décembre dans la dos les speed l'héroïne
à ses membres que vous faites des trucs
là vous tournez l'amour l'après-midi
avec avec romain un film important vous
faites sauter par warren beatty
c'est pas une c'est pas il est important
c'est pas vraiment un scoop parce qu' on
est nombreux
alors il a vu votre photo il a vu votre
photo un lion dans un avion dans l
je vais me taper cette gonzesse il est
arrivé avec ses nicholson que vous avez
monté un attaquant axial et pas du tout
si need a lu alors maintenant
sérieusement les yeux dans les yeux
c'est vrai qu'il a une très grosse [ __ ]
warren beatty non mais excusez moi mais
non c'est de l'histoire qu'on fait alors
fait en fait de l'archéologie de la
modernité là où il peut avoir un petit
corps oui est ce qu'il y avait un petit
corps par rapport à ses habitudes
tout était absolument normale rien
d'extraordinaire
alors comment il va successivement est
aujourd'hui de bastila non mais attendez
c'est pas là j'ai pas vu une [ __ ] non
quand j'ai vu warren beatty j'ai vu
quand même un beau nom mais n'y
intelligent et en plus ça pas été comme
ça ce j'ai pris une tout le temps qu'il
fallait être bon voilà maintenant on va
pas finir voilà c'est léo à temps plein
alors d'ici mardi
c'est l'époque du peuple aventures
d'annie nous en a parlé ici marc bourrel
tout ça c'est vrai qu'à l'époque vous
vous êtes quand même c'est énorme c'est
7 grammes par les gens se demandent où
est la ruine 7 grammes par jour c'est
beaucoup et bien commencé a dit les vous
à se payer ça coûte moins de trente
briques par mois la plaisanterie avait
des personnes donc 7 grammes par jour
trente briques par mois vous commencez à
dîner après vous commencez à braquer les
dealers et quand vous allez vous faire
soigner le traitement de substitution
pour vous donne à l'époque il équivaut à
2 grammes par jour
donc on est en train de s'aggraver exact
donc qu'est ce qui se passe vous partez
aux antilles vous partez à saint barth
d'ailleurs un moment tout le monde vous
croie ou croient morte
un jour ian nicholson qui vous appelle
parce que bernard dauga facci chercheuse
ou partout a donc là
ce avait fait le tour du monde c'était
hallucinant voilà enfin donc vous
retourner à paris pendant deux ans vous
êtes clean et puis pour commencer
richert
cc c'est très dur vous allez être
descendu bas vous avez fait de la prison
vous êtes retrouvé en train de vendre
des journaux de rmistes dans l'argument
dans le métro dans le métro dans le
métro parce que la wii fait froid mais
c'est le moment le plus difficile pour
vous c'est assez ça a été attendez c'est
pas gai c'est très très dur mais en même
temps je veux dire moi j'ai toujours vu
je me suis toujours dit il faut essayer
de j avais toujours l'impression que
j'allais en sortir et qui allie quelque
chose allait se passer quoi que ça
allait pas se terminer comme ça
clochard bas rhin et aujourd'hui comment
ça va alors ah ben ça va ça va super
bien vraiment bien je veux tu prêtes à
bord
clean depuis dix ans maintenant mais
maintenant je suis en pleine forme comme
tout le monde le sache j'ai vaincu
jusqu'à l'aube cette unité
les clauses
au soleil
la collection qui s'appelle pop culture
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant j'ai accueille bénabar
[Musique]
bénabar mesdames messieurs tu connais
mais là bas il était auteur à canal non
un moment j'ai travaillé sur h m
voilà il a fait du cinéma mais notre âge
et finalement quand on écoute ses
chansons ressent toutes ces influences
voilà vous dites bénabar passer à la
télé avoir une ferrari ça m'a jamais
fait fantasmer vous en foutez passer à
la télé vous je m'en fous pas tout à
fait parce que ça fait partie de la
promotion donc c'est quelque chose que
je fais eu de bon coeur et volontiers
mais ça que j'essaie de faire attention
à préfère que sa part a collé un le 10
de métier s'est pas passé la télé et
donner des interviews
ben oui je considère que même si ça fait
partie du boulot encore une fois mais le
principal dans mon travail c'est de
d'essayer de faire des chansons et
d'essayer de toucher les gens et de les
chanter sur scène
vous avez dit je n'attends pas grand
chose de la télé ou de la radio mais
mais oui c'est vrai c'est que c'est vrai
que c'est un plus mais je crois qu'il
faut pas s'arrêter à ça l'important
c'est d'essayer de faire des concerts
plus tôt et 2 et de rencontrer les gens
et vous allez chez moi je n'ai pas
tenable on peut aussi refuser le
racolage de la promo télé
ouais il ya des choses qu'il faut à mon
avis faire et d'autres pas forcément
c'était
bidon
avec des photos de buts en blouson on va
discuter
[Musique]
mais pour deux
j'ai besoin d'être seul je marche la
salle aussi pour faire le point au
contact des éléments de
[Musique]
salle de bain
sans savon
c'est certainement
est ma faute à moi si j'aime le café
l'eau
que j'étais à rennes
allez on
à quoi je me mêle
sur la route des vacances en bon chef de
famille
en face avec un siècle en plastique on
appuie dessus ça sort ça fait porte
gobelets montre très pratique pour
ranger
je n'étais pas de celle à qui l'on fait
la cour moi j'étais de celles qui sont
déjà d'accord
je sais moi
puissiez en public de me tenir la main
et quand vous
ah si
pays des regards
je savais
puis-je noir alors je suis un mais les
yeux
enfants de l'époque
il ouvert
sopo
attache vous
pensent ils qu'il faut pas
sas h monsieur x
dans mes bras au mur
il se fait
rien qu'à moi
il était destiné on a c'est qu'on prend
respiré ou cheveux
et c'est un peu certaines
2 c'est pur
moi je tombais
oh
d'une chaise tu orlando exige le clip
j'étais pas la jolie moi j'étais sa
copine celle qu'on voit à peine
la belle machine j'avais deux ans de
plus peut-être deux en trou et j'ai mais
les gars sont peut-être un peu trop bien
sûr vous aviez des dizaines de
et personne n'avait vu
pendant les fêtes pour hbo
je suis
de celles qui courent
pas tant que des barbares à zilina mais
ce qui est étonnant c'est que en fin de
compte c'est un jeune tard mais qui s'en
sort vachement mais enfin il écrit pour
henri salvador les cris quand même pour
des jets a écrit il ya votre nom en tout
cas sur son cd vous avez composé une
musique pour lui et non non non j'ai
fait sa première partie
mais je n'ai pas écrit pour enfin bon
mais c'est déjà énorme enfin vous avez
dans mon rêve
excusez moi s'est il est ce que le
public veut qu'on garde la bourde de
stevie au montage
alors votre deuxième album qui
s'appelait bénabar s'est vendu à 150
mille exemplaires vous avez fait 150
concerts en première partie d'henri
salvador
voilà styliste est un petit peu dérangé
les clichés personnes avec henri
salvador cours de rattrapage en même
temps rembrandt voilà il n'est pas
encore à lettres s
alors ça vous énerve quand on vous
catalogue nouvelle chanson française
non c'est plutôt c'est plutôt bien et
puis c'est plutôt bien toujours d'être
dans la lumière maintenant c'est vrai
que c'est un peu injuste pour les autres
qui n'ont pas la chance de dainese
d'être en lumière il y en avait fait par
exemple française vincent delerm oui oui
oui bon sanseverino
oui keren ann et benjamin biolay
voilà c'est une nouvelle chanson
française la nouvelle chanson française
sam des gens on a l'impression qu'ils
aient jamais eu le rock'n'roll
c'est vrai que je vois parler pour les
autres mais dans mon cas je suis passé
un peu un petit à côté du nom c'est moi
je puisse écouter des enfants de la télé
oui j'ai de la chanson des textes mais
moi j'ai besoin qu'on me raconte une
histoire quelque chose donc j'écoute est
plutôt de la chanson française mais pas
pour le côté cocardier cocardier de la
sphère qui m'ennuie c'est bien des
chansons il ya un des marolles en fait
vous avez bien les chansons il ya un
début un milieu et une fin qui raconte
des histoires la nouvelle chanson
française est d'accord pour être dedans
ah bah oui la chanson engagée en
revanche c'est pas votre truc à moi
j'essaie de dents dans mes chansons de
dire ce que je pense mais pas aux gens
ce qu'ils doivent penser je cèderai
passer ce cap où l'on commence à donner
des leçons mais je crois que c'est
surtout important de s'engager dans sa
vie tous les jours je crois que c'est
plus important de bien se comporter avec
sa boulangère que forcément dire des
belles phrases de devant une caméra
pensez quoi à gaby de cet engagement de
proximité
fois pour eux serait ou ou là c'était
vraiment ajout dessert tout à l'heure on
peut être des chanteurs peuvent avoir
envie de d'ébranler le monde il y en a
eu et il avoir envie de chanter autre
chose et de faire en tant que citoyen
doit faire mais je vois pas pour en
exclure et la chanson politique engagée
ouais nan tu dis bon le déserteur c'est
bien mais c'est difficile de faire le
déserteur tous les âges voilà donc
préservé mais c'est très compliqué de
faire une belle chanson engagée parfois
les chansons engagées sont un peu un peu
bébête et dans ce cas là ça risque au
contraire de galvauder vous avez fait
une chanson que tant d'enfants twayab
contre le front national
moi j'ai pression n'est pas fait une
chanson contre le français thierry son
niveau d'études et d'intelligence bien
entendu vous dit que c'est un bobo vous
dites quoi
je le reconnais moi ça m'énerve un petit
peu cette cette façon de s'attaquer
justement contre les bobos c'est devenu
une espèce d'aidés nationales si bobo
c'est essayer d'aller dans les brocantes
plutôt que de rester vautré devant la
télé le dimanche après midi
c'est plutôt bien si c'est être
humaniste voter à gauche plutôt plutôt
qu'à droite ou l'extrême droite oui je
suis je suis beau donc c'est quelque
chose qui à priori je défend plutôt quoi
je crois pas que ce soit quelque chose
d'un d'infamant d'être bloqués excusez
moi je reviens sur montrer que vous avez
jamais une chanson sur le front national
avec fumier fumant
non je met justement j'avais parlé de ça
on est en disant au sujet de la chanson
engagée si je devais écrire une chanson
sur france nationale moi je dirais
fumier tout le monde de la chanson qui
que c'est que c'est dégueulasse et et
amoral
il n'y a pas que les lapins qui mélange
des carottes
le petit cochon lui aussi en raffole le
jour des épluchures de carotte c'est si
bon qu'il enchante red rock
alors vous avez vous avez la médaille de
la sainte vierge que votre maman vous a
donné oui sur vous bien sûr vous passez
du budget la corne aussi italienne vient
à tout le monde en parle avec la
médaille de la scène via ce que sa mère
lui a donné un précisé monsieur que j'ai
aussi la corne italienne qui est elle
même complètement païenne donc ouais
des deux côtés on sait rien de sa vie
privée c'est gênant mais non je lis
d'origine italienne en fait c'est à dire
que en fait le dimanche va les manger
des pasta fianarantsoa mancelle qui
n'arrête pas de parler de cul c'est
idéal de parler de cul sans kaka dont on
ignore absolument tout venant et des
îles alors là le questions qui nous
regardent et la raconter il est hyper
physique je veux te dire sont
réactionnaires me suis dit son rêve
c'est de pouvoir allumer la lumière il
ose même pas allumer la lumière s'éteint
oui avec 77 non franchement on a voulu
s'intéresser à ses origines italiennes
je te jure question qui n'a rien à faire
votre grand père était tailleur de
pierres tombales dans le ghetto [ __ ]
deux-tiers voilà tout le monde croit que
bénabar c'est parce qu'il s'appelle ben
à barr pas du tout en fait bénabar c'est
le verlan de barnabé basque avant vous
vous étiez dans un duo de clowns comique
qui s'appelait pas de chalet barnabé et
votre copain patrol vous appelez bénabar
voilà et votre votre vrai nom en fait
c'est comment votre vrai nom bruno
nicolini voilà sans pêche quand même que
on va vous faire une interview en barre
[Musique]
bénabar qu'y at il de plus barbares dans
le monde moderne
l'exclusion au quotidien cette mécanique
qui en place non dans tout l'est dans
tous les aspects de la société notamment
avec les plus pauvres aujourd'hui qu'ils
crèvent de plus en plus facilement alors
que les plus riches s'enrichissent à mon
avis je crois que notre ami cohn bendit
met d'abord en bond colombie
voilà bénabar qu'avez-vous de commun
avec raymond barre pas grand chose je
crois mais j'ai apprécié par contre de
plusieurs fois son sa liberté de penser
même si j'ai jamais partager ses idées
mais c'est quelqu'un qui avait plutôt
rire comme florent pagny on peut pas lui
enlever sa liberté de pensée au
contraire de florent pagny qui à mon
avis enfin moi je n'ai rien contre
florent pagny c'est la chanson en
question et qui m'a beaucoup choqué
poujadiste elle est ouvertement l époux
et elle est irresponsable à mon avis
parce que c'est une chanson qui
s'attaque aux impôts pourquoi pas a
priori mais qui est de fait de façon
très très simpliste il faut savoir que
les impôts ça permet aussi de construire
les écoles de la jv et que c'est pas
uniquement pour persécuter les chanteurs
que célèbre est ce que vous êtes fan des
gros nibards non non vous n'êtes pas fan
des gros nibards semences
est-ce que vous avez une âme de loubards
malheureusement non sur le plan drogue
même si tu es comment par rapport à
pablo escobar au très très long très
long
et vous me raconter des bobards quoi
bien sûr
bénabar de la messieurs l'album
s'appelle
jusqu'à dix métiers
[Musique]
et maintenant basso blind test
[Applaudissements]
voilà et ce soir l'homme a désormais
michel parce que je sais que vous vivez
à los angeles
désormais le blind test et est animée
par un dj différent chaque semaine on a
eu pas mal de stars et ce soir on a un
type formidable qui s'appelle charles
schilling
[Musique]
bonsoir heureuse à voir charles premier
morceau only way
en parler
[Musique]
voilà donc un poids bon l'équipe de
michèle laroque points marqués par
moustiques bravo juillet annonce tic
brillamment numéro deux chantiers
bécaud
[Musique]
dites-moi vais vous parler
michel archambault effectivement serge
gainsbourg avec une intro magnifique
mais devant un petit bout charles qui me
plaisent pas
dites-moi l'avait connu agen le
contraire eût été étonnant
il n'est pas vain soir qu'il refuserait
up
alors on passe au troisième attention
tout le monde se concentre tonia aussi
charles schilling
[Musique]
je le suis
[Applaudissements]
c'est faux
non
cauvin
tesla
ap
sauf qu'avec à popowski arnaud moi je
demande vu l'état actuel de la france
notre rattachement à l'abri
benoît benoît pour le beurre j'adore ice
en gênant la france devrait devenir la
belgique comme injection laurent je
serai albert et non élu qui a plein de
belles géniaux donc ça effectivement
c'était arnaud avec ti simatic ça et
maintenant on passe à la quatrième
charles
[Musique]
non ça sans rien
à suivre dimanche au sens
les flammes
il a récemment
les flamandes dans ce sans mollir sans
mollir on dimanche est donc là je dois
dire que l'équipe de michel laroche
non non non c'est d'écraser l'équipe de
teulat klinsi nations sont éclipsés
[Musique]
voilà là comme vous êtes la barre et
voilà vous êtes du côté de michèle
laroque fait gagner l'équipe de michèle
laroque
j'appelais comment merci en tous les cas
et bravo c'était cette évasion
[Musique]
attention non mais ils attendaient 5
pour michèle laroque 0 pour tenir à
keith singer
la somme est une
ça tombe bien allons-y charles
[Musique]
c'est un grand club et je demande à
ripper
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michel ans
non non non non franchement serge c'est
très cher c'est michelle lang 6,6 et
michel il est gentil kalfon c'est ce qui
me thierry c'est pour tard en juin
attention 7e ciao
mr mobil'emploi marié m'a dit on va lui
couper les cheveux
un tube je ne les garde pas
lol ouais optic 2000 bien si ça leur
canal en france ces atolls contre optic
2000 bien allons-y chili review temps
cronstadt c'est bénabar
ça
[Musique]
des femmes de sa web ce qui porte taille
a clamé chapeau en cuir noir beauté
magnifique madness ouais ouais bien
attention ça c'est pour tenir son père
adoré ça charles schilling
[Musique]
c'est bien
bénabar bénabar c'est un mec vachement
bien
il a été formidable parce que il le
savait il l'a soufflé atone ya hélas pas
percuter tu l'as dit avant mais je n'y a
pas de gp
[Musique]
maintenant nous arrivons numéro 10
mesdames messieurs attention c'est très
compliqué tony ans se concentrent les
mains sur la table tout le monde sait ça
qu'on apprend à l'école de danse
[Applaudissements]
il
sans lui les soldes je vais te dire un
truc gaby ça me fait plaisir de voir que
les cohn bendit sont toujours des
trublions et un 67 ans tu fais toujours
un trublion est ce que 68 ça me fait
plaisir bons amis on ne les écoute pas
et si on les coudes
[Musique]
c'est
voilà
mais si il ya des enfants qui nous
regardent
on peut pas supprimer la tricherie dans
le coin devraient être partagées non le
point est à toi te dis passenger iggy
pop c'est lui la dina puis la malle une
a dit ici pas il faut pas confondre la
tricherie et [ __ ] y ramène à passer du
met alors événement ici pas d'accord toi
tu as dis quoi équipe a gagné
à
de son côté nourrit d'un alors je dis
voilà il faut acheter 10 qui peuplent
vie idiote et lust for life voilà vous
serez content franchement attention ça
[Musique]
rita mitsouko
la scène américaine
[Musique]
ouais on a parlé tout à l'heure les
premiers seront les derniers et vraiment
c'est extraordinaire je sais quoi ce
qu'était qui était content il me prend
dans ses bras pour essayer de t d et tu
me lis graisse jaune
[Musique]
aux essais mais il n'ya pas que les
lapins qui mangent des carottes le nom
n'est pas quelqu'un qui mange ses
carottes et still i peut trouver
blindtest charles schillings non
les résultats les résultats les
résultats
ohlala
[Applaudissements]
l'avènement toit pour l'équipe 2
messieurs maroc trois points pour
l'équipe de tonya kinzinger voilà que
tout le monde est d'accord c'était tout
le monde en parle
ah oui oui c'était tout bon et au québec
qui sera la semaine prochaine
c'était tout le monde en parle mon père
jamel debbouze jamel 100% debbouze en
tournée à partir du 26 novembre
du 23 décembre ou janvier 2004 au casino
de paris du 13 au 18 janvier 2004 au
bataclan du 20 janvier aux familles
2004 olympia michèle laroque venu pour
soutenir son ami gérard l'inter on tire
bien sûr les lapins de et avec jean
pierre c'est au théâtre fontaine merci
maria pacôme me mes esprits c'est
patrick alessandrin avec maria pacôme
shelly dermique ophélie winter michel
muller
clémentine célarié ça sort le 5 novembre
jules edouard moustic journal deux mois
donne 2003 chez flammarion
ça sort le 10 novembre attention le 10
novembre bien les fans là madame céline
ramallah jean narboni du rhony de 10h30
à 12h30 à merci tonya kinzinger sous le
soleil les samedi à 17h55 sur tf1
merci cognard suivi voulez si vous
voulez plus il n'ya pas que les lapins
qui mangent des carottes
steevy boulay album cantina stv
la presse est unanime gabriel cohn
bendit morceau lettre ouverte à tous
ceux qui n'aiment pas l'école s'est
évité
little big man se joue jusqu'à l'aube
avec olivier miclo c'est chez flammarion
l'album s'appelle l'intégrale
rétrospective se joue du 21 janvier au 9
février 2004 7 au centre georges
pompidou voilà bénabar et là bas l'album
s'appelle des risques du métier
en tournée dans toute la france il est
touché 13 février 2004 au grand rex de
paris voilà et charles schillings voilà
charlie mercier fauvergue blandas volume
ça y voilà reporters sans frontières met
en vente trois calendriers 2004 au prix
de 12 euros au profil des gens ne lisent
emprisonné dans le monde et des hauteurs
d'eau sans frontières hills elle a
défend la liberté d'expression merci au
revoir
c'était sûrement pas au rendez vous
[Musique]
et
m
depuis le port
à deux coups
[Musique]
vidéo
non
[Musique]
on
m
après guerre des chefs
benhima
vous
m
[Musique]